all right all right we should be live
huh yeah I think it's going now yeah all
right yeah I don't know what the hell
happened with I mean it's awesome but it
was like looking completely different
than what I did before and it watered
down those songs yeah it's like want me
to download so I'm like what are you
talking about I don't need a download
software it's like they didn't have to
go live button it's the button was
grayed out on the hell's going on okay
I'm telling the other ones closed yeah
so yeah so come in this one all right
hopefully everything's okay
looks like we're going okay so some
peeps are five people over here we got
one like already going already
all right there is hey there weapons and
stuff 93-91
yes okay all right so no people are
coming over here yeah sorry about that
because yeah the first stream like got
messed up and was telling me to download
software who knows what the hell I don't
know what the hell's going on yeah so we
are live now but yeah well yeah but she
can't close it because the door doesn't
really closed all the way um do we have
audio or no yeah are they checking out
hopefully we have audio do we have on if
we had you heard it I heard it when you
get it on over here okay seems to be
working out good okay hope you don't
mind I'm gonna game a drink listen y'all
we're drinking too so you know it's
Saturday night so we're all gonna be
drinking out for however long this goes
on hi everybody how many have we come
into the room thirty real nice thanks
you say it looks it sounds good yeah
okay good we wait a few more minutes
before go stop you guys got any
questions or anything you sent us a
super chat or just whatever we haven't
had a super chat yet we don't know if it
works or not
yeah I mean I
think I enabled it but yeah we'll see
how that goes so hey this our 200th
episode you guys yeah hi from Tampa live
in Tampa like a long time ago back in
2000 2001 something like that I so go
back there
how about the camera angle if he's good
yeah it looks like I haven't moved or
anything drinking uh el Jimador tequila
the Reposado version with [ __ ] rock
star
what flavor rock star as the regular box
kind of like so slightly like Mountain
Dew gotta come about it hmm
I doubt that's what it tastes like I
just you know II you don't dress well
didn't that's like a double whammy it's
like tequila in to inner don't learn two
things I don't like together that don't
they're not good when they're together
got a super jet 5 pound weapon stuff
okay thank you very much it's working
all right thank you very much the the
bogan not bogan dogs are my favorite
conspiracy Bogdanoff bogdan augers the
logs and knob I never heard of that yeah
break more on that one I got caught a
vise lon that's [ __ ] straight out of
Tijuana
also we got some war a 24 ounce PBR just
made a big Frito pie we just had hot
dogs yeah that's what right here DJ man
yeah okay yeah yeah Frito pie yeah I've
had that for with the frito chips and
the uh yeah yeah I'm yeah you can use
like refried beans or you can use uh
what do you call it damn taco taco
hamburger taco flavored hammer hell yeah
of course I'd probably get her furniture
there's no conspiracy about two really
weird-looking all right damn is drinking
crystal skull honor the paranormal field
mm-hmm
connivance lon he's coming live from
Chazz the [ __ ] liberated zone down
there trying to [ __ ] fertilize the
crop was crops with human feces well
that works yeah got tom-toms guys old
man glasses on yeah yeah see because we
have I got a read yeah I got a read a
day normally we're not well normally
we're not all that blind but I need
glasses to read yeah I think just looks
for look at my phone it really sucks
because I used to have like impeccable
thank you very much Melanie yeah thank
you very much would you say $50 yeah
$1.99 yeah $50 congratulations on two
thank you very much you guys this is
like really really awesome so here I
know we did this what like the other day
like as a test and I feel bad like not
warning people but it's like we weren't
really sure I was just like look just a
couple days before we do the 200th
episode I need to test out to see how
because I never did it before and I
don't know how the hell it works so I
said I need to like do this and so we
just like 10 minutes before we went on
we were just kind of like you want to do
it right now and it's like okay we'll do
it right now and then we didn't really
expect to be on there talking for like
an hour but you know you know how we do
once we start talking can we expect
Dennis to make an appearance possible we
should go get Dennis let him be on the
bridge let's see if Dennis has anything
to say about being in the Illuminati or
perhaps being a reptilian I believe he
will fall I'm not sure I'm not silly
enough to believe in reptilians what of
course you know conspiracies do happen
everything is a conspiracy any kind of
teamwork as conspiracy so of course and
you know and when you're involved in a
conspiracy and you get caught the best
way out of it is just to say it's just a
theory
so yeah don't be a good show well yeah
and I mean that's kind of where I stand
on conspiracy theories I feel like the
however many people there are involved
in this suppose
conspiracy that's like inversely
proportional to like how much I think
that it's real or not like conspiracies
that are real tend to be like smaller
conspiracies like that's totally legit
but these ones like I said these big
world-spanning conspiracies like the
reptilians or the Illuminati running
everything or something like that
there's like you can't get more than
like three people to agree on [ __ ] so
[ __ ] that
now I come from a different world okay I
come from armies and armies are [ __ ]
large groups of [ __ ] thousands and
tens of thousands of men that actually
get together train and conspire to
invade other countries and to just
[ __ ] [ __ ] them up
all right now soon people say well
that's not a conspiracy no there was a
lot of conspiracies that are along that
lines for instance Germany's fake war
against Poland they [ __ ] grab German
prisoners out of their own prisons put
them in German uniforms and polish
uniforms shot him on the border and then
[ __ ] cried saying that they got
attacked by Poland yeah it didn't happen
all right
they it was a conspiracy all right
Toland didn't attack them
Germany [ __ ] was like a cry bully it
would attack you and then say stop hurt
no you they would attack somebody and go
stop hurting me stop hurting me they
also like isn't it also alleged that
they that they also started the
Reichstag fire oh yeah that wasn't then
blamed it on wow that's not like that's
a conspiracy but that wouldn't have
taken that many people to log some
undercover SS or others to cover of
Gestapo guys this is early on in before
the Third Reich had really formed but
the Nazi Party had a lot of power in
Germany not a little power though they
found a mentally [ __ ] guy oh no what
do you call the mentally handicapped
yeah you call it nowadays but back in
those days he just said butter started
all right and they he was Jewish if I
remember correctly and they met him in a
bar and convinced him that he had to
take it upon himself the Reichstag yeah
and they
the tools evidently to do it and I think
he might have been drunk when he did and
he did it when they were waiting right
there yeah now to grab him and then they
were going like hey the Chi was burned
down the Reichstag that sounds like
something but they put him up to it I
mean that sounds like something the
Germans yeah it's not just a German a
lot of government that's what a lot of
special operations and intelligence
they were so MCI does that yeah there
was something that I heard about earlier
the Dreyfus Affair which actually
happened in like the late nineteenth
century that was also kind of like where
they took one a Jewish you know ooh
thank you very much deejay main echo and
thanks Melanie she actually did give she
said oh she just Oh were they so thank
you very much you guys where they
actually took this one Jewish French
artillery guy and like pretty much
essentially framed him and saying he was
like passing secrets to the Germans and
stuff like that so you know so it does
happen like I said somebody's to ask if
what we think about David it gear or we
can't figure out how much we are going
to talk about him yet because reptilians
is one of my very favorite just because
it's so wacky and it's like I can't and
now I mean not only does I'm gonna say I
because that sounds yes like less stupid
than you also hit nine thousand subs
today did bow I thought it was just like
$10 that was Zach says did you hear the
movie's release date from no time to die
moved forward a week you gotta be more
clear I thought that was that wasn't
coming out until December I thought I
thought November but I'm not really
because I thought didn't they usually
put them out I usually thought that
James Bond movies came out in like the
autumn like November right around
Christmas time I always thought yeah I
never thought they were like summer
blockbusters or anything like Santa does
on there he's saying they're aliens on
the moon aliens on the moon there's just
like a couple
reports of things from ex astronauts
where it looked like there was some
spike looking things coming up but it's
got to be just rock formations if aliens
were ever came on the moon or left any
artifacts behind they'd probably leave
it on the dark side of the moon
I would think aliens came but that's we
can't talk about that today I don't
think well we didn't we talked about
faking the moon landing didn't we I
think we talked about that back on
episode 50 or one of our lifelong
specials we were talking about like
silly yeah
like space consumed conspiracy theories
I think and one of them was like that
somebody had faked the moon landing
which just seems like a really big
problem to me I mean it seems like it
why it seems it much easier to go to the
moon than to go through all the trouble
of faking it and having to like cover it
up and aliens came on the moon chucked
angles next book yeah well there's like
a [ __ ] I'm sure that someone's fetish
somewhere again the bomb movie I think I
thought it was supposed to be in July
that it was so original
no I'm pretty sure that it was
originally supposed to come out I mean
because even though we saw the previews
I was like wow that's a long time away I
thought it was coming out in like new
members I liked I liked all the other
bob movies that had go what's his face
in it on today Daniel Craig yeah but
someone said this leaked out [ __ ] that
he said over this new one and just the
way movies has just been sucking so bad
recently I don't know man I think we'd
be lucky to get a good chase Bob oh
thank you John thank you for your
donation do you see that no I can't oh
yeah that's appeared yeah thank you
thank you thank you very much oh watched
shows no start just a bit thank you very
much what you're gonna have us on again
yeah I'm gonna be I think I'm gonna be
doing something for they're doing up
in September we'll see now that the new
bond is you know but they've been
[ __ ] all of all of movies and
Hollywood been [ __ ] up recently
they're losing billions of dollars with
stupid [ __ ] they're just gonna have to
stop trying to market movies for a
[ __ ] slims take a big tempo movie and
trying to market it to like a [ __ ]
10% of the [ __ ] global population you
kind of gotta be have wider appeal you
know and I think what's coming back as
things like traditional movies you know
a lot of the movies at me and Jenny like
are almost they're like 80s on Mars
movies one better thing to particularly
uh thank you Matt Roman very much for
your donation one thing that I think is
particularly in regards to or and sci-fi
another plus of going like doing a
throwback may be like said the 80s no
cellphones because like if I was writing
a horror movie like nowadays
I would totally set it back because
having cellphones and having modern
technology it's like it makes everything
so much harder unless you're making a
movie about that technology which I
wouldn't do because it would date the
movie too much yeah it makes a lot of
horror things impossible to write it's
like you can't really have a lot of
isolation yeah you can't really have a
lot of the same like situations that you
could have had like in the 70s and 80s
before there was like ubiquitous social
media and all that kind of stuff
and so I mean I have seen some recent
horror movies that were based around a
particular technology you know what I
mean there was one called
open windows that was kind of about like
you know surveillance and all this other
kind of stuff and those are good but
it's like it's just like I would never
do a sci-fi movie because unless you do
it a very particular way like you know
2001 or like that where you kind of go
like a little more philosophical with it
it's just gonna date you know what I
mean it's like you see sci-fi movies
made like a lot of sci-fi movies even
good ones they came out in the 70s and
80s and it's just like the technology is
like nothing like that now you know what
I mean so it's just kind of like I don't
know it's a you're really like if you
want longevity in the movie I feel like
you're really shooting yourself in the
dick like making something that's so
focused on
technology you know what I mean um look
at all those [ __ ] movies they made in
the 50s with like these [ __ ] giant as
computers and all kind of stuff that's
like now it's like wow you know that
[ __ ] came out yeah for sure
but yeah so um let's see I don't want to
do like a couple of shout outs I'm did
mostly shouts before he's like I think
I'm the sidetrack show but um in case
like people don't watch and stuff and
like I said I'd like to do them on the
main show as well because you know just
in case people don't see the sidetracks
ones so I wanted to say hello to our
newest patron whose name is Austin so
hey there also we had a patron before
like named Janet who actually increased
her support this past week I also want
to thank Sandra or Sandra like I'm sure
I'm pronouncing pronounce it either way
for a PayPal donation and also I wanted
to thank Dominic again for sending me
the blu-ray of Texas Chainsaw Massacre
very excited as I feel booked blu-ray
yeah because I actually have not I don't
have I don't think I have that movie on
DVD now that I'm thinking about it just
really weird that's I need to hand in my
horror card yeah but yeah so do you want
to start talking about you and I don't
know you want to start with the
Illuminati you want to start with
reptilians you wanna know I started
aluminized you want to start with
Illuminati so that's who I had that was
worth all this [ __ ] now
so like I said I have like a bunch of
notes and stuff but if we go off on
tangents it's fine it's a 200th episode
we just want it to be like a fun time
you know what I mean
so the Illuminati kind of has I mean the
Illuminati was a real thing so whether
or not you believe that it's still
around or it's like has to do with this
cabal of people that are still like
controlling the world and she'll like
that that's a different question but
they did unquestionably exist for a
brief time beginning from 1776
so the Illuminati very closely tied in
with the Freemasons the guy that founded
it was named Adam vice vice couch I
guess is how you pronounce it I'm not
German as you can tell
um he was actually in the Freemasons or
wanted to join the Freemasons but kind
of got you know disillusioned they
weren't really like doing exactly what
he wanted to do so he started his own
he's like well [ __ ] this I'm gonna start
my own secret society with blackjack and
hookers that's not what he said exactly
but you know I'm imagining now
originally it was called the
perfectibility for fective Billis
because his whole thing was he was a
very like enlightenment guy and he
wanted to you know essentially say that
man was perfectible and just you know we
always striving to be better and you
know using reason and enlightenment and
things like that so the name Illuminati
which came about later
basically just met illumination you know
illuminating people's minds through
reason and like you know the preaching
they were kind of not preaching but you
know tolerance they were very anti you
know anti church not in a horrible way
but like in a way that you know we don't
really think that men you know they
wanted to get to a point where men would
not need masters yeah they were anti dog
but yes a lot of a lot of the actual
Catholic Church I'd love to omit the
dogmatic [ __ ] [ __ ] in and lots of
corruption and they were trying to get
away from that the man could man could
reach like spirituality and
self-actualization through a process of
enlightenment learning which and I'm
done with that you can do that yeah and
this is not an this is not a new idea
this goes all the way back to ancient
[ __ ] wrong oh yeah okay the cult of
Mithras back in the Roman days was a
competitor to early Christianity before
Christianity was like a religion was
just called Mithra ism is like a
fascinating not much other it survives
but it seems to have been what you'd
call a mystery religion and it was
something kind of like these guys you
eat everybody went in you could be of
any kind of class you paid money they
gave you courses they did a bunch of
damn astrology and you moved up in the
levels so this is not a it's like making
a [ __ ] a wizard
[Laughter]
they got dudes out there you don't mean
that'll pay to become a lizard for
titles and [ __ ] I can respect its and
you're basically you basically join in a
Star Trek oh really yeah people can do
that as long as you're like knowing know
that that's what you're doing then I
don't have a problem at all in fact some
enterprising modern individuals have
actually taken this whole Illuminati
thing and like base all these conspiracy
theories that think the along Illuminati
still exists and that they run the world
and everything they have made like
websites called like Illuminati or join
the Illuminati or whatever so that you
can actually pay and join it and you can
have like a little certificate that says
that you're a witch like I said I wish
I'd thought of that
yeah the real Illuminati though I
they're gone okay
yeah they they lasted less than a decade
yeah they were kind of like the
Rosicrucians or the Masons
they don't run the world when now there
aren't groups they're trying to run the
world but we just call them globe lists
the globe well the Illuminati they
didn't I don't know if their end goal
was to like rule the world not
necessarily they did want to kind of I
don't want to use infiltrate because
that sounds a little too sinister for
what they were trying to do but trying
to influence they were trying to
influence the thinking of the time but
like there was light yes so they they
had good intentions I don't think there
was anything sinister about that very
similar to like the Masons the Shriners
yeah they're like you know we'll hang
out in our club houses and we'll learn
study all this [ __ ] and we'll recruit
members from across all society and in a
time our good teachings will permeate
the culture yeah that's essentially what
they were doing they weren't trying it
wasn't like anything underhanded or
anything it was bad times when all this
was going on - I mean it was extremes
you have extreme wealth or extreme
poverty so you know I mean society kind
of needed [ __ ] like this and there was
no telecommunications but no nightclub
scene no internet no telephone no that
so you had to have these physical
meeting houses and you know in these
secret societies today would just be a
damn discussion group on [ __ ] on a
message board something like that and
the thing about the Illuminati as they
truly exist
was that I mean when they started out it
was only really just like a handful of
dudes and you know from what they can
determine even at their like massive you
know their biggest size it was only
between like maybe 650 to 2500 people
that's it so it wasn't like this big
huge you know influential it's like they
might have had a little bit of influence
here and there but to be honest they're
anti-clerical kind of like anti royalist
type of leanings sort of got them in
trouble so they were really only around
until about 1787 at which point the
Prince elector of bavaria which is where
the illuminati originally came from he
kind of shut him down and like you know
wouldn't allow them to operate any
longer because he thought they were a
danger to the church a danger to like
that you know the royalist power
structure yada yada so um they didn't
want anybody around that was like
talking about free thinking or talking
about enlightenment talking about you
know tolerance they didn't want anybody
doing that so they were essentially you
know crushed out of existence
like I said they may have had a little
bit of influence on the culture here and
there but not not to the extent that you
know that people might think now for
whatever reason so like I said you know
they did exist if it wasn't necessarily
it wasn't like an offshoot of the
Freemasons like I said because I think
that the two of them getting linked all
the time there's a similar type it would
but it was a similar type of thing you
know and there are a lot of competitors
there also
Rosicrucians it's yeah now these groups
were pretty um they were wealthy guys
most of them and guys are well-connected
they did have an impact all right yeah
but but I would say more so the Masons
the Masons had a lot to do you know with
the creation of the United States most
of the yeah most of the guys that helped
found it had Masonic backgrounds lot of
pirates and seafaring merchants you know
we're all into Masonic ideas and it was
because the Masonic teachings had a lot
to do with democracy
yeah and they wanted to bring back
Democratic Republic's onto the earth
this is their intimate everythin's
monarchies monarchies and theocracies so
in some ways you could say that
the Freemasons
Rosicrucians and the Illuminati they
were all kind of like the high-tech
progressives of the day yeah I mean they
were trying to make things better and
even nowadays even the Freemasons that I
think they get you know probably maybe
not nowadays but I think they get a lot
of [ __ ] because it's a secret society
they supposedly all these weird rituals
all this other kind of stuff but in
total it really seems like mostly what
they do is just raise money for
charities I mean that seems to be please
what they do now yeah that's pretty much
mostly what they're doing I think the
need forums kind of passed yeah I mean
you know they get together they have
their ranks they have the thing but it's
like really now depending on the lodges
because Freemasonry is not you know it's
just it's more complicated just like
everything is it's it's not like one
monolithic thing there's a whole bunch
of different lodges some of them allow
women some of them allow atheists some
of them you know I mean so it depends on
where in each country has their own it
was they were religions but they were
secular religions yeah they believed in
kind of like a thing like a grand
architect or grand builder they didn't
really they really named God or in the
way that Christians and she day type you
know religions did where they gave God a
name and stories didn't they have that
they allowed anybody from any religious
background to join you just had to
believe in some kind of higher yeah like
a creator higher but like I said there
are some lodges nowadays that will admit
there are drawings of you know
George Washington being signed into
office and he's wearing a down white
apron with a compass on it ness that's
not I guess it it and if you look at the
capital buildings and the layouts of
everything and all the motifs that's all
Masonic yeah even on the American money
you know what the all-seeing eye and
everything it's all Masonic codes which
I know most of them and I think a lot of
people like because
that's something that's brought up a lot
is the pyramid with the eye that's on
the back of the dollar bill and I think
it's an all-seeing eye it's like you
know it's all tied in with New World
Order Illuminati all that kind of stuff
but all that's supposed to be is the Eye
of Providence like God is watching over
the Creator is watching over us whatever
if you count the number of bricks going
up a number of levels on that damn
pyramid this 13 of them over 13 colonies
yeah also 13 is like a number of [ __ ]
reincarnation recreation creation and
destruction 13 is kind of like the new
numerological [ __ ] numerological yeah
and they were saying what it means is
and then like it's set behind it it's a
barren plain and in front of it is a
bunch of trees you know it came from the
wasteland that's what they're talking
about the wasteland is theocracies
monarchies you know a great temple you
know a 13 yeah so 13 Revolutionary
colonies and then in front of it it's
got all the trees and it has a great
future ahead of it yeah and you know
it's like but like I said it's not I
don't think there's anything sinister in
it they liked the symbolism and they
like this you know of of us coming out
of like you know what they considered
like like wasteland yeah like the
monarchy yeah they wanted something
where it's because finish sonic kind of
concept monarchies and theocracies were
a wasteland because they didn't have
reason yeah these guys are all into
reason and logic and [ __ ] this is it
pluribus of them you know from from many
we have become one yeah you know it's
just yeah and that that's that can mean
a lot of things you know I mean [ __ ]
from from many colonies we're not one
thing from a multitude of people we're
now yeah lots of different people yeah
everything in all their symbolism and
all their their motifs with could be
read four or five different ways they
were big into that yeah that's why it
all sounds so vague because it was
basically word magic
we're and picture magic you know because
Dada this stuff came from a time when
the average person was illiterate but
they knew everything about icons yeah
even their store signs were just icons
because there's person couldn't read so
but if you walked down Main Street
somewhere in the 1700s there were these
icons and pictures and words so a
literate person would know what it was
an illiterate person wouldn't know what
it was yeah by the drawings out it and
there the whole books showing you the
old icons they used to use not all of it
real not a lot of it's just real
apparent I mean like two hammers you
might think that me a blacksmith but it
may not be - hammers might mean
something else you know hmm
two hammers just off the top of my head
oh thank you Nili for your contribution
this is everybody saying um yeah
somebody asked and this is actually a
good question we're talk about the
freemasons he said if there's nothing to
hide why keep it a secret that is
actually a good question I'm not saying
that they don't have anything to hide
I'm just saying that I don't
particularly with the Masons I don't
think there's anything particularly
sinister going on there but I do think
that there's kind of like and I have
this too so I understand it um I think
there's kind of a thing where people
like to be in something that's like
exclusive or that other people don't
know about it's the whole thing we're
like you know hipsters like some band
that they in like when too many people
like them they can't like them anymore
and it's like everybody likes to be kind
of like in the know and you know about
[ __ ] that other people don't know about
which like I said I think that's another
thing that makes conspiracy theories
like particular conspiracy theories
attractive to people is you feel like
you know stuff that the rebel don't know
and that kind of stuff so people like
you know people like having secret info
you're answering that question of why
were they hiding in AFER's yeah yeah
another thing was is that what these
guys were saying they were saying in a
lot of times in countries where you
could get killed by saying that that's
another thing - yes you were talking out
your talking out against the kanger you
were talking out yeah sure which in a
lotta [ __ ] Q yeah which in a lot of
ways you might have I mean it might have
been their own thank you again take it
to the liquors to
so you know people take freedom of
speech they take that for granted
nowadays back in those days just kind of
a harmless discussion about a certain
topic could be construed by a secret
police are talking out against the king
yeah which if you did not they could
like get off right you know what I mean
so yeah so like you said you could
really get in trouble for saying some of
the stuff well I mean look at what
happened to the Illuminati it's like all
they were doing and as far as I know
they weren't like looting radicals or
anything like that
they were just enlightenment-era they
were like you know hey maybe this whole
like theocracy thing or maybe this whole
monarchy thing maybe it's not such a
good idea it's like you just say some
[ __ ] like that
and they'd be like off with your head
you know I mean so you really had to
like mind your P's and Q's the
monarchies were run by a royal by a
royal class and their royalty was
divinely supported yeah because they
believed in divine rulership yeah
Divine Right of Kings Divine Right of
Kings you were King and you were a king
because God said so yeah alright so if
you said that that dude is not the king
or the King [ __ ] sucks not what are
you saying that the King sucks you're
saying the god sucks yeah now if you
said yes search sucks you've now said
that god sucks and the Kings yeah and
even in was never like that in the
United States but in the colonies it was
yeah I'll people forget that the United
States on paper it on paper started in
1776 but in reality it wasn't until
about maybe 1810 1812 took a long time
18 war of 1812 that was really when it
was settled that yeah I guess the United
States is a real thing but even back in
the colonies you said the wrong thing
you could be killed
so yeah depending on the colonies
because some of the colonies like I said
some of the people that came over here
you know when you're a kid I don't it's
probably better now but like when I was
a little kid in school everything they'd
you know everything was like oh we just
came over to your afraid about religion
and everything was awesome
everything like that that's really how
it went in practice because it really
does seem like even a lot of the
colonists that came over here some of
them were chill and cool and everything
but I'm worn a lot of them were not like
a lot of them were a lot more Puritans
yeah and I like the Americans they were
kind of like the Anglo American version
of Isis she [ __ ] said the wrong thing
and hang you yeah which yeah they might
it was something stupid like your
interpretation of a certain verse in the
Bible can get you killed
yeah that's up so like I said you really
had to like you got your ass back there
I guess you've really had to lie so in
that era you have to understand that
these secret societies were [ __ ]
centuries ahead of the average person
just walking down the street yeah and
you they just couldn't show their hand
to the average people back then now they
were getting purged out later on too
yeah Bobby these guys got killed and
their religious reasons yeah they were
basically heretics yeah and like I said
I mean the guy that founded the
Illuminati Adam Weiss out of ice out um
you know he's probably lucky that he
didn't get killed but I mean they did
shut down to [ __ ] just exactly for that
reason because that's what because he
was talking out against Authority who
saw me on against you know ruling class
he's talking about of about the church
and stuff like that which you really
didn't do back then so I can see how cuz
that's the thing we were talking about
this a little bit on one of our other
shows where you know just because
something is secret like that like the
Masons who have like supposedly like all
these weird secret rituals that have to
do with like you know put a noose around
your neck and you know with the sword
and everything like that they seem
strange but it's like it's really just
like a ritualistic symbolic type of
thing which a lot of rituals that people
do all the time anyway and it's like not
I guess people don't think about it
because it doesn't seem that weird from
what I've heard I've known a couple
people that were masons and they're not
really supposed to talk about what they
do and stuff but some of them have said
oh you know we do a ritual like this
done dancing and it sounds weird but
it's not they're not like sacrificing
babies or they're not doing anything
particularly nefarious it's just that
some of the rituals they do or like a
little bit strange if you just like
to walk in on somebody talk about the
skullenbones Skull and Bones Society
basically was a Fraternal Order that's
that's out of was it Yale because I
think it's Yale yeah yeah yeah that's
more like a frat house yeah it's like a
yeah and that's all the [ __ ] sons of
all the rich boys you can't get in there
by being a nobody and they kind of take
an oath of loyalty to each other at a
young age and then as they move on into
other places in government and industry
there it's like a mafia of favors and
yeah evidently like a lot of your CIA
guys are [ __ ] skullenbones yeah a lot
of presidents are a lot of likes people
that are in the government have been
yeah but it's like I said I don't I
don't necessarily see anything
conspiratorial in that it's just that
you know the the scions of rich families
tend to all go to the same like elite
schools they tend to all like they kind
of all know each other sort of oh thank
you very much Paul G they they kind of
all know each other they kind of like
you know each other favors and you know
I mean so it's you can call that a
conspiracy if you want but it's just
kind of like moment of social scene it's
like a social scene with really really
rich people I mean the same thing a look
you know to use an example like you know
we're in the God scene here Orlando
Tampa it's like if one of our friends
has something go horribly wrong like you
know we all know we all know about it
it's like everybody kind of pulls
together tries to help them out it's the
same kind of thing except these people
are like billionaires so I guess it
seems more sinister in a lot of ways it
is because people that are billionaires
and stuff ever and they have power or
Idol but so so I don't know if you want
to call that necessarily call that a
conspiracy theory or not because people
in power want to stay in power they I
don't think it's so much a conspiracy
like let's all get together like in a
room like any Specter and like talk
about all the horrible [ __ ] we're going
to do and they all have like similar
goals yeah so I don't even think they
have to talk about it because it's just
kind of like that's what they're all
working toward individually or in small
groups and so that's just how it comes
out yeah the weapons and stuff mentioned
Specter yeah Specter in the mood in the
James Bond flicks
does exist there just showing it in a
more solidified form to represent kind
of like an alien's force what Spectre is
is corruption that's what they're
talking about very rich and powerful
people are also they usually tend to be
very bad yeah you just don't get that
kind of power without being bad some of
them came from families that we've been
bad for generations and they make a lot
of money illegal in doing illegal things
yeah all right and getting away with it
because they have piles of money you
have power piles of money and then power
inside governments and friends inside
governments or they connected into it so
basically what you're talking about is a
very very rich man's mafia - something
like that exists yeah it does it does
now
today I'll carry little rings and do
they all have none I don't think so no
things just something to kind of
naturally form that's what I'm they have
and they even have like [ __ ] I don't
know I'm a don't want to say his name
I'm just gonna call him child Island man
all right they got a lot of child Island
man child Island man did not take his
own life
okay they got a lot of that [ __ ] going
on that a lot of that kind of stuff when
you had that kind of money you can go to
other countries and you have friends in
other countries where the laws [ __ ]
different you can buy if you can be
pretty much just do whatever you want to
do it every like I said I don't consider
like the reasons like I don't consider
that that's why I don't buy I feel like
old loominatee they brought anything
everything it's like I'm not saying that
I don't think rich people do whatever
the [ __ ] they want to do cuz they do
obviously I mean that's a big duh and
everybody knows that but I'm just saying
I don't think there's anything like
everybody sitting in a room and we with
all these plans and cackling we're gonna
do this that the other thing I just
think that they have particular goals
and most people that are billionaires
have similar goals like they want to
keep all their money they want to give
all their power so it just kind of
naturally goes in that direction it
looks like it was orchestrated in a
place like a fur ball it happens
weapons and stuff mentioned they also
have dirt on it yeah they have dirt on
each other yeah and having dirt and on
each other is a lot of leverage so you
end up kind of forming a mafia basically
is what ends up for me you know I mean
you can't rat on other people because
they'll read on you and yeah they'll
walk like a video yeah and I believe
that child Island man I think what child
Island with what child Island man's
Island was all about was he went to this
island and you had sex with these
underage girls and they had videotape of
it and that's what got you into the club
yeah because now everyone was equally
compromised so well it's kind of like
what they do when you join Scientology
that's why they put you in a room and
having me like talk about all your
deepest darkest secrets and they
videotape you so then that way if you
ever want to leave they have to debate
it on you they have [ __ ] it's do that
really what Scientology stick and a
carrot if you want to make all that
money and you want all that power you
have to give them a stick to use against
you
yeah sticks and carrots and I think that
nexium cult was something like that yeah
that was very similar Scientology is
also like that I think and I think
governments were involved in it too
would not surprise me if an intelligence
agency maybe several intelligence
agencies upfront the child Island
because it makes sense it makes sense
that that kind of information would be
very valuable to governments and they
would probably pay a lot of money for
that that does make sense yes so I was a
child Island man made money from very
different from very different many
different directions not only do they
make money from all these deals yo so I
think sold his information to
intelligence agencies in other countries
that's what I think yeah and I think
those countries were taking that
information and doing things like
learning learning how to bet on the
stock market how to predict when certain
things would go bad
or when certain businesses would because
you can make a lot of money knowing what
you you know I mean knowing things or
having access to information those guys
actually had a lot of money the guys
that have all the money know what stocks
are gonna fail and which ones are gonna
succeed cuz they're gonna pull our money
out of it that kind of stuff yeah I
still can't believe I know this is like
kind of Africa of nothing but I still
can't believe [ __ ] Martha Stewart got
in such a prison for insider trading
yeah they're all doing that does it I
mean it's like why pick on her I need
somebody I guess she but they can send
anybody to prison they sent a three-star
general prison on little flimsy [ __ ] if
they want their there are so many laws
they can send anybody to prison well
yeah if this shit's got to be changed if
you ask me yeah they can send you to
prison over a victimless crime it's it's
just got to change yeah which that may
be one good thing that comes out all
this demonstrations of chick Martha
Stewart is gangsta as she is actually
[Laughter]
she just didn't I don't remember her
ever bitching about it she was like yeah
I'm going to prison she should've got
like some [ __ ] Prison tattoos or
something like that that looks like a
brand she heard by saying yeah yeah so
what were you talking about
Oh Illuminati so alright so there was a
book that came out in 1798 which was
called proofs of a conspiracy and this
was like an anti Freemason book but the
Freemasons and the Illuminati were
already kind of considered to be sort of
like the same thing at this point so I
think this book was kind of like the the
thing that may be sort of like
catapulted because it was referred back
to you by like a lot of writers later on
that started writing about Illuminati
and how they run after how they run
everything and stuff so you had books by
they kind of like had some writers in
the 20th century that took those ideas
and you know tied them in with like
anti-semitism like protocols the learned
Elders of Zion that that book and then
you have like some people that were like
anti Roman Catholic
kind of getting in on it and putting
that spin on it you remember like
[ __ ] Jack Chick is that still alive
the one that made this the Jews little
yeah actually the logic
is he dead yes did he even say he's like
he didn't draw this city because some of
them are like drawn differently those
are batshit crazy they still like if I
used to have I might still have it
somewhere I have that again I have the
Halloween one the little booklet where
do you guys know what a chick tract is
yeah I don't know if maybe not maybe
people not in the u.s. don't know what
that is [ __ ] wouldn't know what so
Jack chick was this really really
religious crazy person yeah he was crazy
and he put out what these little
booklets they were like little tiny
comic books and they're held Chick
tracts they would give them out for free
yeah he had like a foundation or
whatever found a Russian when I was like
in fourth and fifth grade and people
would stand outside our school and like
get them out that's where I got at the
Halloween one they give him a little
kick everything's evil essentially yes
little comic books that besides the
dollar bill but they were probably 20
pages maybe 50 pages and they were
actually like when you're a kid they
were like awesome comic books but they
were [ __ ] scare the [ __ ] out they all
basically were about going to hell
yeah what you're doing you're gonna go
to hell and [ __ ] we would like we had
kids with them back and effective yeah
I'm not really sure if anybody if
anybody out there has ever been
converted by reading a chick tract just
let us know I mean even even in the
third and fourth grade we kind of
smelled the [ __ ] we just kept him is
we thought they were funny like yeah
we're like this I have I still have the
Halloween wood I used to have more I
used to have one [ __ ] man I can't prefer
what it was now but I used to have one
that was like right on the cover the
Halloween wooden used to crack me up
because but you know obviously look at
me Halloween is my favorite holiday and
probably has been my entire life so this
[ __ ] that I'm reading in there about
like all the witchcraft and like all
it's a satanic panic kind of [ __ ] like
that everyone knows is not true and so
I'm just like reading this as a kid if
you're so full but it was super fun
anyway like I said I still got it
somewhere there no I think I sent it to
somebody actually like when we remember
we did one of the mail outs and I was
just sending like random [ __ ] to people
like patrons and stuff that I had around
the house I might have sent it to
somebody but I might
don't have it so um yeah so everyone's
got a version to this Illuminati thing I
think you've been crazy old pat
robertson's got one his is kind of like
weird I don't even know what the hell
you know he was doing there but then
there's also some with like ties it was
like New World Order and nine 9/11
truthers and all that kind of stuff
there's also these two guys named Mike
warnky and John Todd who are some of
those like Protestant evangelists that
claim that they used to be Satanists
which I'm sure is [ __ ] because a lot
of them yeah it hasn't all employees
yeah we did all this weed and all these
rituals and we killed babies wait you
know impregnate a woman and for some
weird reason yeah just just jump out the
rest of the guy that's what I mean it's
like come on no one's follow me asked
about the Shriners did they really come
from the Mait from the Knights Templar
I'm gonna say no no I don't think so I
mean the Shriners are kind of an
offshoot of the Masons a little bit and
the Masons and the and the Knights
Templar so there's like their
similarities there but I don't know if
it's the original Knights Templar I
think they were all just kind of
disbanded like they were yeah
you know there was some other [ __ ] also
like the Cathars you're supposed to be
wiped out but then there was one
historian net said that he didn't
believe that he went back and that there
were some references to some Cathars
getting wiped out but it was the
reference was several centuries after it
supposedly happened there's no evidence
that there were ever any Cathars that
that might have been something that just
appeared at somebody's story and there's
a lot of that a lot of things that
people think are real there isn't even
any evidence for well particularly going
back that far it's like if and I think
we talked about this a little bit um we
might have talked about this a little
bit we're talking about like 40 in
archaeology and all that kind of stuff
where sometimes like if you're a few
hundred years removed from the context
of whatever this was that was written
yeah in those days you're not really
sure if it was written as a joke maybe
it was because I think people tend to
think that nowadays is the only time we
do like Oh
found-footage or like meta-narratives
and stuff like that but they did that
[ __ ] back then too so sometimes they
people would write things like as a
satire and then if if the knowledge that
it was satirical got lost over time and
like if you write it nowadays you would
think holy [ __ ] doesn't the other thing
was going on but it was like written as
a joke
there are also old artifacts you know
that from Mesoamerica you know with calm
does exactly what I'm talking about
these little Mesoamerican figurines they
look like spaceships and all kinds of
[ __ ] weird alien creatures and [ __ ]
but if you stand back and look at what
you're talking about is you're talking
about like the first examples of what
you would today called like kawaii yeah
things that are car you look cute cutie
figures and you know like a kawaii
version of a [ __ ] fish it looks kind
of like a jet or a kawaii version of a
damn butterfly yeah and it kind of looks
like a airplane but you know I mean so
this because you were so removed from it
we don't really see the style yeah I
don't understand a star I wrote an
article about those about those little
figurines that yours oh look it's an
airplane no there are little cutey
versions of their stylized yeah very
clearly and it's that they're like
bulbous and round and you know a
thousand years from now they might find
a [ __ ] Hello Kitty was that real
creature black penguin thing oh my god
no I want to go forward in time just
yeah what is that somebody says I hope
Pookie makes it entrance yeah whatever
she must have fallen asleep surprise
though somebody asked about your recipe
again because some people drink for
waves because some people came in they
didn't see the very beginning this is el
Jimador reposado tequila
yeah and rock star and a splash in life
yeah rock star rock star
greatest rock star did it yeah it's like
not a weird flavor because usually you
get the what the hell that other stuffs
the tropical tropical red black red but
actually I actually like the rock star
better yeah right
oh no they all taste the same to me like
she's got a [ __ ] terrible says it
tastes I do not she doesn't like
anything this tart that's not true I
just don't like energy drinks yeah I
like most other things if I had a
terrible sense of taste that would mean
that like all your foods gross because I
eat all your food and that's delicious
I'm better than it when making flatbread
I'm making [ __ ] bad-ass that's really
right and it makes the whole house right
because you believe you've been making
it in the cast-iron skillet in a skillet
yeah it's so easy I just I got some damn
dough sitting in there each time I want
a piece of flatbread I just pull a piece
off by the size the egg and flatten it
out and throw it in a hot pan and like
three minutes later a fresh [ __ ] big
[ __ ] not bake but the fresh piece of
flatbread yeah and alls it is it's just
water water it's just water
yeah that's water water flour and baking
powder that's it and a little bit of oil
yeah yeah and then we you can put
anything on it like anything on because
we had like some leftover like what we
have like support you and we have our be
shrimp shrimp shrimp of it yesterday we
put some like pork tenderloin in and
then I put some pickles on yeah hey we
just ate hot dogs before I'm on putting
a flatbread recipe in the [ __ ]
cookbook it's like I I really want to
get this cookbook going but it's like I
don't know I'm just I got so behind
because I got like like I said I think I
mentioned this on this on the other wife
share but the this week I was kind of
like oh I'm gonna do all this research
for the 200th episode like I'm gonna do
Illuminati and all that kind of stuff
and then like I got like these three
humongous like graphic design jobs like
old boxes and
books and also they're kind of
definitely gosh it took hours and hours
and hours
this hand yes and I'm gonna see we're
gonna see Missy Dennis when I get more
tequila in it yeah and then yeah there
are and then Dennis will come over here
and I gotta feel sexy for Dennis to come
out cuz Dennis always has this sexy
energy where he's feeling sex but nobody
else is feeling sexy feeling sexy this
is some women's underwear [ __ ]
heartbeat and tie himself up itself in a
hole yeah oh thank you very much Mark
Lilly says try Indian stuffed breads oh
yeah yeah stuff not oh yeah that's a
good idea
Tom makes a lot of Indians we make a lot
of that's probably the that's probably
the cuisine we make more than anything
else I would think or used to be like
some days we would make Indian like
pretty much every day like a huge part
of it so yeah okay so I was talking
about these two guys that are Protestant
evangelists right and they said that
they used to be Satanist and guess what
they also said that they were in the
Illuminati and that Illuminati is the
highest level of Satanism he says that
he went to this conference it was all
like Satanists and witches and stuff and
then but I guess he went to it and he
was like oh this is too much for man
then he left and the name Quinn joined
the Navy converted to Christianity and
now he's all saved and all this other
kind of crap so yeah so these two guys
are basically saying that the Illuminati
are a High Council of druids and they're
trying to destroy Christianity and make
witchcraft the official religion of the
United States how's that going Tom
Merton says never trust a man with a
mustache that wasn't born only to kind
of mend wear
cops and gay cop what about seventies
porn stars I ask you gay cops I guess
they could also be cops for Jacob hey
cops yeah yeah did we ever do a show on
Spring Heeled Jack we did actually we
did a show it was the whole thing wasn't
about him but we did one that was [ __ ]
man what else was it I think we talked
about like the mad gasser of Mattoon and
like kind of all these like crazy bring
hail Jack was the original [ __ ] Park
Park for experts I kind of loved the
idea of just a guy getting it in his
head like however long ago that was I
was like yeah because it was around Jack
the Ripper but I love the fact that this
was something that was like really ahead
of their time that's like I'm gonna go
out and put on a [ __ ] oilskin suit
and a cape and put on like soup like put
on some British goggles or something
like that and jump around and freak the
[ __ ] yeah yeah and what they're
describing is parkour so yeah essential
jump from rooftop to rooftop jumping
down from the roof land on the [ __ ]
top of the fence and then jump down from
the fence breathing fire that's somebody
who's trained the oilskin suit was to
keep himself from burning up from
spitting that fire in case he got it on
himself it's probably what that was yeah
I just feel like it was maybe something
his performers and they did it to women
or teenage kid having fun and doing
parkour and it was like a stunt and he
did it to women and never hurt anybody
so he's impressing the girls well
because if I was that like I said it
would be like seeing like a like an
impromptu circus for yeah you're just
out like going about your business
toddling about the streets of London or
whatever and then like suddenly this guy
jumps out breathing fire and jump into
like walking up the wall and [ __ ] you'd
be like well he's remembered so yeah we
still remember him nowadays a steampunk
Batman yes yeah this wasn't in the
folklore upset yeah we didn't I can't
remember one else
no we didn't mad gasser mattoon on that
show and there was a couple other like
cases that we kind of all threw together
that we're all kind of similar urban
legend II kind of kind of stuff do you
ever think you will do true crime we
usually do do
DJ maniac says I'm a big fuck-off
Mountain man because the court just
started opening up the barber shops here
today yeah yeah so apparently YouTube's
the cesspool of a hive of scum and
villainy or whatever
apparently there's a whole bunch of
videos of people on YouTube that say
that they used to be in the Illuminati
here that they are whistle blowing on
the Illuminati or something to which I
asked why are you still alive if it's
like some big secret and they don't want
you knowing about it
why are they letting you put up a
YouTube video exposing all their secrets
see this is another thing that I can't
get behind with all the conspiracy
theories because I'm just like if they
didn't want you to know about something
or they didn't want you talking about
something you wouldn't even be able to
be on there they would just like take it
right off so some people you know some
people are using Illuminati as a
misnomer they're calling Spectre the
Illuminati we already tell I already
told you what Spectre was yeah you guys
have been with us you know since the
beginning of the show it's just a gang
of rich people like the child Island man
who didn't kill itself there's lots of
those you got some people calling them
the Illuminati what that's one of them
missing chat children [ __ ]
notification is it well not necessarily
it might be or it could be whether
somebody I subscribe to with live okay
but yeah just because you got child that
child Island man that doesn't mean that
that he's Illuminati more like Spectre
well and the thing about it is that
everything in you know I was kind of
gonna get it into conspiracy theories in
general and why they're so prevalent
it's not like it's any different
nowadays like people have always
believed conspiracy theories I think
they just proliferate more nowadays just
because of social media because the
internet people can just hear about
things
after I think that's all it is but I do
think that there there does seem to be I
think one it's like human brains are
very adept at seeing patterns which is a
good thing normally but I think they're
also pretty adept at seeing patterns
that maybe already been there which that
can be problematic but also I think that
it makes people feel better
to think that there is some kind of
structure or reason or something like
that behind bad things happening rather
than thinking that sometimes bad things
just happen randomly or it wasn't or it
wasn't the result of anyone's will or
anyone like sometimes it's just that's
what you're saying is true most of the
time but not all the time usually huge
political events are they're staged for
instance like what's going what's going
on now with like some of the riots and
protests many of the people that those
riots and protests are people that
joined that riot in that protest but
there was some financing and
organization behind that there are
groups that do that they do it for a
living
they were bricks and and gasoline placed
out certain areas certain things have to
be orchestrated so there is a level of
political organization between things
that seem to be chaotic but you know it
is you know it was that a natural event
now the timings all [ __ ] wrong for
all that [ __ ] first you have a trade war
kicks off then after that you have a
[ __ ] pandemic where not enough people
died they said it's three million but
it's really just a few hundred thousand
and then that kind of died down and then
all of a sudden a global revolution
kicked off and it all kicked off around
the same time in other countries that's
a level of organization you know you
know I mean definitely people are taking
pictures like hey what's the I've seen
the pictures pallets of bricks there
there's no construction sign gun going
on there are organizations that do that
and Tifa is one of them
now this is a struggle for power going
on has to do this election coming up and
there was a one world government forming
that is falling apart and they're
blaming it all on Trump when that
there's got to probably fail anyway
because there were a lot of a lot of
members for trying to break out of the
EU and a lot of things didn't go right
central in South America so stuff like
that is not a conspiracy it's just
political activity is organized all of
it going all the way back into the 1800s
and the 1900s you rig things you rigged
elections you you [ __ ] hired you
hired people to make strikes happen any
hired strike breakers and then you you
know you just you paid people off you
had you know if the election campaigns
that's all just part of that same system
so is it just random and you're just
seeing patterns don't know you know me
being the military man I know that it
takes a lot of organization to get like
[ __ ] like that done it takes money
that's been funding sorry yeah I'm just
saying don't know what I'm not saying
that I'm not saying everything is random
okay I'm just saying sometimes things
that look organized but not organized or
not as organized as people imagined that
they are because the creation of the
United States was a conspiracy it was
organized but like I said that nation is
a thing you can't water the term down so
much that doesn't mean anything but what
I'm talking about is that like I said
I'm not saying that everything that
happens is random obviously causes have
effects I'm just and you know but I'm
just saying that some things that people
attribute to like some grand scheme is
not necessarily a grand scheme or wasn't
planned ahead of time I think sometimes
there are like some little plans every
year like yeah we kind of want to go in
this direction or we kind of want to go
in this direction and then things just
happened that weren't really intended
but it looked like it was on purpose
that's what I'm saying because I'm just
saying that there are too many
contingencies there are too many
there's too much randomization
there are too many people go in their
own directions for everything to be
perfectly engineered toward one goal
there's always gonna be some [ __ ] that
is unexpected there's always gonna be
some [ __ ] that goes wrong that's why
like I said if I believe in conspiracy
theories like you know Watergate for
example which is you know an example
that is used a lot you know that was a
real conspiracy but it wasn't a huge
conspiracy and it didn't stay secret for
that long because deep throat came out
and spill the beans about it so I'm just
saying that the larger an alleged
conspiracy is the more likely that we're
gonna find out about it like immediately
because people can't keep their mouth
shut right some I just mentioned will
heat me in growth which that that yeah I
was gonna say that I saw the heat Negros
real thing and Nixon talked about it
yeah that's just a meeting where they
all go and there's a big owl and they
just like yak and they some of those
larger tapes where Nixon was recorded
talking and he mentioned Bohemian Grove
and he said he went some year and he
quote he said it was the faggiest thing
he had ever seen
sounds like it was a thing I've ever
seen sculling bombs it's a rich boy club
yeah they just want to go and play dress
a dress it's basically like cosplay for
rich people yeah okay know what I think
it's a better better description it's
more like summer camp for rich boys yeah
they could go there and they don't have
to worry you can run away from their
work and they can run around half-naked
and have sex with prostitutes of [ __ ]
either sex and nobody gives a [ __ ] and
they can all hang out with their own
people and really a they do see
themselves as another species they see
themselves as above us so I believe that
and and they're gonna and they are kind
of a secret society in a way of where
it's kind of like a code of silence you
know I mean they all go to this [ __ ]
summer camp retreat and be [ __ ]
basically well horrible which I mean
it's like there's nothing there's
nothing sinister about
they're not killing people they're not
sorry it's like dance to be killing that
it's like they just want to go and get
their freak on yeah
owl up there and we've all done that I
think it's a thing's supposed to
represent [ __ ] some kind of wisdom
it's um it's it's some [ __ ] lame
yeah because didn't the Illuminati I
mean their symbol was the owl and stuff
as well so it just means like wisdom and
there's everything there like a little
bunch of bunk clothes like hotels that
they stay at in that area and it's Nixon
wasn't impressed
well Nixon wasn't impressed he thought
he thought he said this the faggiest
thing I've ever seen he's a bell well
it's Jones so I can broke into the place
and got it on video it's [ __ ] awesome
I thought I saw that but I was just
kinda like I can't I can't stand Alex
Jones so like I can't I can't stand he's
a hot water filter salesman all right
he's [ __ ] uncovered a lot of [ __ ] is
it one of the author's everything he
totally vitamins vitamins all those
crappy vitamins it's just he's just
making money he's just making but he's
uncovered a lot of [ __ ] though yummy he
does hype everything up is a great show
I think she doesn't like the sound of a
man's voice no I don't like my list in
the last podcast not that much yeah I
can't stay in his [ __ ] Plus easily
plus he's alone you would never make it
in the army you'd never make it
yeah because it's just what you have to
put up with is that all the time yeah
that's what I mean I can't I can't stand
shouting [ __ ] that's why I
didn't join what is that's why I didn't
join the military got a lot of [ __ ]
shouting I'm like show up cool infantry
was just one long tough man competition
that's what it was
is that well at one long tough band
composition see I don't know you say
tough man I see I see a lot of like
insecure people like just trying to like
yelling oh they weren't a security phase
it's like as your baby so like I said I
can't
yeah that's cool it's like that's why I
would never join them because it's like
I don't need like [ __ ] people
shouting like yeah I heard you just yeah
he says last podcast on Leopard I love
that [ __ ] show man
I listen to that I started listening to
it I had heard of it like for a long
time but I just never got around to
listening to it because I don't usually
like listen to a lot of podcasts and
stuff because my mind tends to wander
like if I don't have something to look
at but I'm more a reader but I started
listening to them when I was like doing
I can't even remember like what it was
one of her true crime shows that we did
and they had done like a three-part
series on it I'm like okay I've heard of
this show we'll see if it's any good and
so I listened to it and it was hilarious
and I was like oh my god so then I just
like started listening to all their [ __ ]
so I've even listened to ones now where
if they did a show about something we're
doing a show about I always listen to it
like a day or two before we do ours just
so I try not to like repeat their jokes
or anything but also the cool thing
about them is that even though the shows
are hilarious they're also really well
researched and a lot of times they'll
come out with stuff that's not in any of
these it's not on the Wikipedia page
that's not because they'll do like they
do a lot more research than I do they'll
like read like all the books about it
they're watch all the documentaries
about it so it's like they you know they
know like all this [ __ ] about it and
they are all comedians so you know the
three of them like interact really well
together it's like really really funny
so I don't know if they did a show about
the Illuminati or not yeah guy said that
yeah I'll be insecure guys do get weaved
out in basic but when women don't [ __ ]
and she wasn't there I'm just a girl
I'm just a girl I don't understand Jenny
I'm a rare exception
Jenny kind of likes lab would call soy
boys she likes soy boys I don't know why
she liked me but but I've also heard
that most women they kind of like soy
boys but they don't sleep with soy boys
they like [ __ ] me they like [ __ ] guys
are totally the opposite then I don't
know like I don't have a type
particularly I tend to like people who
are
smart I tend to like people who are
funny I like people who are fun I like
people who are like laid-back
I don't really I don't like people that
are like really like [ __ ] oh I can't
stand that kind of are people that are
like really rigid or anything like that
I need somebody that's like her first
husband was rigid as [ __ ] so I don't
know where you get he's well I didn't
know that initially like he didn't
really like come off that way at first
um so it took me a while to figure that
out but you know he had like other
qualities and I liked them but yeah he
turned out to be like a lot more rigid
than I then I thought that he was and
that's like really really hard for me to
deal with like that's why it's it's
funny because we don't surprisingly um
we don't get like a lot of abusive
comments on here although I should
mention and I'll come back to what I was
talking about a second ago but remember
when we did the show on the West Memphis
Three last week and I said every single
thing that I watched on YouTube about
the West Memphis Three and I watched the
ships and the stuff had this same person
commenting yeah and I said I bet they'll
cut he'll comment on this show too and
he did what he said um I don't even
remember because it was like really
really long I'm like oh it's that guy
and he sent me a really really abusive
email which I kind of skimmed that I'm
like yeah just like [ __ ] because
that's kind of like the best way to deal
with that kind of stuff I mean every now
and then like I'll get a really shitty
it's weird because I feel like West
Memphis Three that was the first one
where we actually got you know it was
just that one guy that sent us this
really I mean if for him to like break
these three huge long messages like on
YouTube which I deleted and then he sent
me two emails like really really long
and I was just gonna lie until that's
mental and I was like what the hell is
the matter with you I'm just like I'm
just gonna delete that and like ignore
you so why usually when it's like real
real long that's yeah you cuz obviously
you have nothing better to do with your
life then go around just like watching
it's like I don't really carry
schizophrenia yeah there's something the
matter with you this like I said there's
millions and zillions of videos on
YouTube that I do not agree with but I
have much better things to do with my
time than go watch them and write a big
long [ __ ] screed about how much you
suck for making it it's like I'm just
not gonna watch it
and go do something else that's what a
normal person with all that write a
[ __ ] book write is that's what I mean
it's like I don't really get it but yeah
so other than that really the only
abusive comments we get we got most of
the shittiest comments
weirdly on the ed and Lauren show
anytime you talk about what hucksters
they are or sometimes the paranormal
cases like people got really butthurt
about the one we did a long time ago
about like the school experience no
experiment no no that should happen yeah
so anytime you're like skeptical like
you can talk about true-crime all day
long but the second you are skeptical
about like a ghost story or something
like that people get really really get
upset about it yeah as Dennis Ness
people getting upset it's gotta come I
gotta start channeling Dennis yeah yeah
somebody pointed out I said he probably
copy-paste the comments if that was it
is that invested yeah probably because I
was like I said I didn't read the whole
thing as soon as I realized it was that
guy read the first couple senses I'm
like I know what's this dude I got a
feeling he was gonna comment cuz I saw a
comment on every other one now one of
the back Co Illuminati one of the
funniest things about the Illuminati and
one of the most what the [ __ ] why is
this even a thing and I'm not even sure
like what the Genesis if this was but
for some reason pretty much everybody in
power that is said to be in the
Illuminati but for some reason a lot of
people are saying like jay-z and Beyonce
or what and I'm like it was random um
and one of the things like I because I'm
watched I didn't want to watch like too
many of the videos of like people that
believe in this [ __ ] cuz that's like I
don't want all the recommendations and
the [ __ ] that goes along with that
so I try to curate I hate to get all
this stupid grab my feed but um
basically from what I could discern from
normal people that made videos about
this kind of [ __ ]
was that the reason that they get called
out in particular a lot of times is
because apparently I don't know a lot
about jay-z or Beyonce cuz I don't they
you know follow the kind of pop music or
mainstream music or anything cause I'm a
hipster but it's because they have like
their record company or jay-z's record
company the the logo is like a triangle
or a diamond or something and so a lot
of times like Beyonce and stuff we'll
make that like ass hand symbol like that
and that's supposed to be Illuminati
like you know it's like the pyramid
that's on the back of the dollar bill so
because they've made a triangle thing or
I think Katy Perry was supposed to be in
the Illuminati too because one time she
had a costume to have like an ayah bra
thing on it or something I don't really
know so now I mean the funny thing is
that now that people say that about them
now they are trolling everybody and like
taking it as a joke and being like oh
yeah totally
we're totally in the illumina now
they're doing it on purpose just because
people are stupid and they think they're
in the Illuminati which I don't know why
people wouldn't figure out that's
because if somebody said I wasn't the
only one it's definitely what I was
already asked what a silly boy was I
hate that [ __ ] term I really do
a SOI boy is a low testosterone male who
didn't really go through puberty proper
properly you can recognize them as being
common you know they're not they're
either very skinny or they're overweight
they have beards and make this funny
[ __ ] smile where it's like it opened
their mouth up as far as they can to
look as non-threatening as possible
they're kind of simian and behavior I
would say complex kind of like an
effeminate monkey it's kind of how they
act
they're so effeminate so so feminine is
bad no not feminine feminine so it's so
like a woman is that that's what I
always like butch is right on it man you
know that's what always good snails
about that yeah so you want to make it a
sexual thing no well because I mean the
fact that you're using like
quote-unquote feminine qualities as an
insult that's I don't like so I'm just
saying it's awful
strange on a man I'm not not
gender-bending in that way yeah but some
people aren't really doesn't have
anything on a stash shop okay okay
there's a hierarchies the gay scene they
understand this exact will tell you all
the bad exact exactly
there's tops and bobs okay there's tops
and bottoms city that's just that's just
what I'd like to give her okay you keep
all right
Oh somebody says this is Dan bellows
awesome yes it is yes yes I love
Danville he has the best voice yeah he
is so funny
yeah it's like all of his shows are
funny he does this great thing called
quiet time yeah where he basically just
has he has all these because he has shot
like 40 billion hours of video that he's
like over the either the audio is bad or
I didn't think it would make a good show
or whatever so he decided to just take
it and just like quietly like tell
stories over it like about stuff that
happened when he was a kid or paranormal
experience or something like that and
it's so [ __ ] great it's like he just
has the best voice also they do another
dirty room which is hilarious and
gag-inducing all at once they just go to
like the worst hotels and motels like in
America and stay in them and the main
like stay in there for hours and hours
and then they just rate the room they
have like he has all the [ __ ] he has
like all the [ __ ] he has luminol he
has [ __ ] what's the blacklight stuff
and he's got like they've got like the
little things where they can swab for
blood and semen and all this other kind
of stuff and they just go around and do
the tests in the room and it's like
every single time they go in a room and
it's like they've found some horrifying
[ __ ] I mean one time they found like a
plastic bag to look like dirty woman's
underwear like under the bed they find
crack pipes and [ __ ] needles they
find one time they found like bloody
like handprints like although it wasn't
you couldn't see it but like luminol you
could see it and it's just like every
time like a new indignity or like some
new disgusting thing it's like Dan's
like oh my god and it's just like his
voice just like it cracks me up every
time he gets so [ __ ] offended like
it's like you know bugs crawl out of
this [ __ ] and there's a thing who's that
guy that's on there Rick Serra that big
fan
okay that dude is [ __ ] hilarious and
it's like he's got have gotten into a
thing where he'll uh he'll eat the soap
yeah like he kind of got into a thing
where they make him like ether sex on
there going how I had you guys know I
was gay Zach made you gay so is Dan bell
though yes yeah cool [ __ ] I know like I
said he's got a great voice and he just
like he clearly like loves what he does
we started watching him at first because
of the dead Mulvaney is because we
certainly got into the dead balls but I
think probably another dirty room is my
favorite just because even though I gag
or each time I watch it it's like really
disgusting like all these [ __ ] places
they stay but yeah so you want to let's
talk about reptilians then yes about
time drink though you need to get a new
drink are you gonna go get it yeah I'm
good I'll just like yeah oh that's right
we can't stop and edit oh [ __ ] is there
any way you turned off have a break no
no way to even do a break I'm not
allowed to do that yeah somebody says oh
the outcasts are murders did we do a
show I can't really did a show about
that because I remember I wrote about it
and then I watched that Netflix
documentary that I'm pretty sure we did
we did a show about it I get so confused
because we've done so many shows and I
also write books about true crime cases
so sometimes I can't remember if I
actually just wrote about the case or if
I wrote about it and we did show about
it or something yeah when dan bell yells
oh I know that's a and for a while like
before the quarantine and everything
they started doing the another dirty
room they did like a whole bunch of live
ones like they live streamed a whole
bunch of them and I didn't know that
because I'm not usually like on YouTube
I don't usually have it open so I don't
see like when people are alive and so I
just discovered like a whole cache of
another dirty rooms that I hadn't seen
that he had done all on live stream
because I think they don't sleep in the
rooms because the rooms are disgusting
and no one should sleep in there and
probably they get staph infections and
malaria and who knows what else but um
they they usually stay there I think in
film between three and four hours and
then he usually edits it down to about
45 minutes or an hour or something like
that um speaking of hotels will you ever
do a show where you go to the hotel
Hotel Aileen Wuornos stay that um we
should probably do that we haven't even
done a show about Aileen Wuornos yet and
we probably should because she I lived
in Daytona like I'm from Daytona I was
born her so and I still lived there when
she was doing her thing and I think
actually speaking of Dan Bell I think he
actually did go to that motel or he like
went to other place like he went to the
bar and Daytona like where she hung out
and all this other kind of stuff so I
probably we should because a lot of my
relatives like my brother and his wife
and like some of my other aunts and
uncles and stuff like that still live in
Daytona Beach and I haven't been back
there for a while it's only about an
hour from not even an hour I think it's
probably at 45 minutes because we're
like a little bit outside it's about an
hour and a half from between Orlando and
Daytona but we live like about 18 miles
outside of downtown windows were like
closer to Daytona yeah so he said I
think you did it yeah pretty sure we did
all Kassar murders I mean I'm pretty
sure we did it was an update on the
McCain case um yeah there was they
caught a guy I can't remember they
somebody that I saw I watched another
true crime channel on YouTube Stephanie
Carlisle and she did an update and she
was talking about the guy that they
caught his name's Christian be but I
can't remember she said what his last
name was it did start with the B but I
camera four it was um and she seemed to
think I don't know like I don't know a
great deal about it it's like she seemed
to think that he was probably not guilty
I don't know like she did another like
two-part thing about the medal and
McCann Ches like before this happens and
I haven't watched that so I don't know
if she was leaning more toward the
parents being involved or it just being
a random stranger I mean I don't really
know I wasn't there like we did a show
about it I I don't know the parents did
some sketchy things but I
really I don't know if they had anything
to do with it or if it was just like a
case of cuz there were like kind of a
lot of other sketchy people like hanging
around there and the guy that they
caught he was doing some [ __ ] like he
had robbed some I mean he did live in
that area at the time that she was
kidnapped he had robbed some of the
other you know places and other houses
in that resort so he was and he was
known to be you know kind of a pedophile
had to get sexual assault against women
against children and other kind of stuff
so he does like kind of fit the profile
but she seemed to be doubting that maybe
it was him because he doesn't match any
of the witness descriptions of any of
the people that were seen but I don't
know if that necessarily means anything
we don't offer or not the Madeleine
McCann case somebody asked me about yeah
ELISA Lam case did we talk about that we
talked about it I still am didn't we did
I thought we did it I don't I don't
remember doing the whole whole show
about it but we might have done one with
like two cases because I'm pretty sure I
remember like editing that video into
the show yeah Zachary says damn does
that Christian B have a billboard of
before daddy yeah indeed he does yeah
German Nueces affirm the Thompson kita
are strong how strong is my guitar Jen
it is pretty sure pretty strong at the
club yeah we got a lot of gay friends we
do yeah and it's the club my best buddy
[ __ ] is a leather daddy like straight
like we're talking about a [ __ ] Rob
Halford Judas Priest style yeah it's
cool as [ __ ] but can probably have
Monticello on the day we should we show
them to come over yeah he's cool he said
he's an RN he writes
yeah and he's um he's 50 yeah although
you wouldn't know it tell you stories
but he's a really good shape he's he's a
cool guy he's cool as [ __ ] man [ __ ]
show up to the club no suck in tight
leather and [ __ ] with his [ __ ]
leather jacket with the cutoff sleeves
and spikes and everything out there
dancing and the girls just
up on him and his [ __ ] dick is like a
[ __ ] huge for you and it's like a
wraps around it's his [ __ ] leg on the
side and looks like he's got an orange
and he'd be out there dancing and this
[ __ ] tight ass other than the women
just staring dead a yes looking right at
me and Jenny would be [ __ ] well this
is really good dancer it's up to so it's
like you know yeah I just [ __ ] with
him all totally man why are you denying
all these women just they eat it was
funny that because drunk he does like
women he loves Jenny yeah it [ __ ]
fogs up honor and tries I got it like
[Laughter]
yeah as access I want to hang out with
you guys there Florida yeah we are we
are pretty fun yes we're enjoying the
live stream yeah we like yeah we'll do
more oh yeah we should actually know
that I've kind of like figured out how
to do it and it's gonna like yeah it's I
think I was a little more stressed out
before because end I've eaten and I've
done um and I've done some other like
radio shows and stuff like that that
we're live and I always get like really
really stressed out because I mean I get
stressed out before we do the regular
show - even though which is dumb because
I know that it's tapes and I can just
like edit out if I mess up or anything
like that but this one I was at this one
I was more worried about you know what
if like you have to go get a drink or
what if I have to go to the bathroom or
something like that then I'm just gonna
be like sitting here like staring into
the camera but then it's it's easier
because I see people here and it's like
they're asking me stuff so it's kind of
like a Moms Club game to get guys off
Jace Clary [ __ ] Florida is a [ __ ]
very special place it's an magical today
here imagine and we're talking about
we're talking about
that are [ __ ] all regulars in our
scene and everybody's almost kind of
like we're all related to each other and
we all have pasts like we've all dated
each other and [ __ ] [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
has happened you know people in couples
and [ __ ] just weird [ __ ] and half the
people are like your ex or something
yeah just yeah it's a it's a different
situation
yeah it's you can't really keep secrets
everybody knows nobody knows everything
it's almost like being in a cult
kind of yeah it's like a sex cult some
of the girls are some up they work for
Disney Corporation so yeah we know a lot
of you knows a lot of a lot of people
work for McCann girls porn stars yeah
they're very large I think isn't really
the second largest producer of for porn
yes sir LA yeah and or maybe Miami yeah
and like it's like titty fetish porn
girls and just weird [ __ ] and like buy
it you know you later
my ex yeah she's doing some yeah we're
doing some just you just you never can't
really tell what's gonna happen yeah
yeah now everybody's up everybody is
that some weird [ __ ] but everybody knows
that it's okay everybody knows his long
sharp you're right yeah because I mean
if we do know a couple people like a
couple people but we do know some people
that have done some really sketchy [ __ ]
yeah I'm talking about probably like
drug yeah yeah this kind of ban and yeah
even though they still come out like no
like everybody [ __ ] with them shunned
them afterwards which I mean they can't
really kick him out of the bars because
they didn't do anything in the bar yeah
and then like weird [ __ ] appears like
some of the most uptight straightest
[ __ ] girl that you would think
[ __ ] just peaches and flowers of [ __ ]
she's hooking you find out she's hooking
remember her yeah that was some weird
[ __ ] yeah that actually did surprise me
not much surprise
whoa yeah see that kind of goes back to
what we were saying before where
sometimes people that look really weird
are like more normal than people that
look normal yeah you look at a normal
person you're like no really because
they're like passing yeah right they can
get ups all kind of [ __ ] cuz I think we
were talking about it in terms of serial
killers not that we're saying that's
same thing serial killers obviously but
it's easier to be into sketchy [ __ ] when
you don't when you don't stand out yeah
and then you'll find some god [ __ ]
Queen that's been around forever and
she's sucking just this God this [ __ ]
then you find out she's a prepper and a
[ __ ] survivalist knows everything
about all that [ __ ] beauty we begin
to like Alex Jones and like incoming
Civil War and owns a bunch of [ __ ]
assault rifles and guns and it's good
good with [ __ ] you know I mean you would
never suspect well yeah I mean it's
weird because I I kind of feel like I
mean I guess it's just like any
subculture you always you always think
of it as this big this big like
monolithic yeah kind of thing but I
think the God seems just like anything
else it's very diverse yeah you know
what I mean it's like there's all kind
of different people and you never really
know what they're gonna be like even
though you may think you know just
because but that's that's never the case
that's why it's never that's it's never
a good idea to judge people what they
look like no matter what kind of aztlán
says eyes wide [ __ ] we started at that
like you know you found out what we
thought we ordered it we were like why
is it taking so long from Poland yeah
copy I ordered I gotta fruit that prices
come from Paul woods with blu-ray yeah
that's a good movie it's not like I said
it's not not my favorite Stanley I'm
gonna go back and analyze that [ __ ]
because Kubrick was warning us his
daughter said she knew about sex cults
in the very rich upper class she must
have been talking about he must have
been talking about child Island man the
man's a child Island man let make a song
for
for some reason that sounds like it they
might be genuine sauce guess he particle
crunch - when a man can own a whole
island it gives him the ability to evade
law enforcement that's really your
fantasy wasn't it Dennis
I'd love to Bonin Islands yeah there are
a lot of got Monica a lot of rich people
like you can put all the barns on it
that you are rich people like me Jed I
mean you think you see me as an unusual
character no I'm very normal the people
up top they're all like me I believe
that yeah yeah okay so anonymous
automaton asked did a lot of people
speak Welsh in Wales or as a dying
language um the thing okay so I was in
South Wales and from what I could
determine not a lot of people spoke it
like in the streets or like as the firt
as the first language from what I could
determine I think that it's more
prevalent in North Wales that people
actually that that's their first
language and then they teach language
later however my ex-husband who was born
there he actually went to school the
first up until he was 11 years old I
think all of the schooling was in Welsh
now they do have English language
schools obviously just like they do in
England but they also have Welsh
language schools so if you want to you
can send your kid to a school that's
also all the topics were in Welsh he did
have English class too because he you
know and he spoke English at home
because his parents did not speak Welsh
but he did learn the two languages like
simultaneously and so I do feel like
last I heard and it's been a while since
I looked at it last I heard 200,000
people still spoke it in the world which
is not a lot but they have been trying
to kind of you know get it back into
schools teach you back in school so
light so some of the you know some of my
ex-husband's relatives like nieces and
nephews and stuff like that they were
actually pushing to like you know make
everyone bilingual all the signs are
bilingual you know you can buy
everything all the books they're
bilingual and stuff like that so they
are trying to preserve the language
because they don't want it to go away
but um
that I only ever heard one person and it
was an older lady like speaking Welsh
like just around you know what I mean
like I was in Cardiff I think and I was
in a shop and her maybe a filly I can't
remember and and she was speaking Welsh
to like a person in the shop or
something it was very funny because it
was like a Welsh gift shop and this
woman goes up and starts speaking Welsh
to the girl behind the counter and the
girl Kenard who speak well she can
always speak English so she didn't know
what the old lady was saying so I
thought that was kind of funny but um
yeah as a native language I think pretty
much they all speak English as a native
language but they do they're trying to
preserve the Welsh language by teaching
in schools so everyone's bilingual all I
know about Wells just from the movie
evil aliens I tried to learn it it's
like I still have like all the tapes in
the book and stuff like that I did
pretty much okay on it but the
pronunciation is like really I think I I
tripped up on it a lot because you know
they have most of the same letters in
the alphabet they have a couple extra
ones like they have like a double L like
is a letter on its own because it's
different for nunciature than a single l
but because a lot of the letters look
the same but they're pronounced like
completely differently than they're
pronounced in English so that really
kind of like tripped me up a lot you
know I mean like W is a vowel and it's
just like it's it's crazy
um but you know it's it's kind of neat
it's like a neat sounding language I out
son you are right over there yeah yeah I
love the Welsh accent it actually it
almost sounds like they're singing when
they talk which i think is kind of neat
isn't it time to start the lizard people
stuff yeah you want to talk about them
and live streaming for way over an hour
yeah it's up there it's one hour and
thirty seven that's pretty good actually
I'm surprised I haven't like I didn't
even have to like get another tracker
this is a pretty strong drum to you guys
yeah I made that hopefully I'm not well
that's probably more than because when I
go to a club yeah it's like I usually
you know have like five or six of them
before I even feel anything but those
are small but these ones you
I maybe drink two and then I posted yeah
I'm so happy I made it for the live
being that I'm in Australia I was
worried I would miss it
currently laying a bit hungover but I'm
here yeah we figured we were gonna do it
tonight but then we had a couple people
say Friday but most of the people said
that they were calling us out to
manikins do and now I will that's weird
though it's like usually mannequins
that's usually a Friday night thing
because usually it is Black Friday so
it's like Gotham darkwave and now I'm
kind of bummed because our friend
Dimitri was DJing tonight so well nobody
warned us and we had already planned to
do this anyway so it's kind of like I
didn't want it so it's gonna be weird
because now we're doing that we're doing
the episode for Tuesday but we're doing
it right now and people are seeing it
right now and then it's just gonna be up
I'll have to put something else up on
Tuesday dealing we've been in there
movie reviewers Alton just so I don't
feel bad about not having some well
don't worry about it just post this well
it'll already be posted that's what I'm
saying
cuz I do like to post something every
day but we but we thought well we can't
really go live on like Tuesday morning
because who the [ __ ] gonna watch that
you know what I mean I'm not worried
about you get on David icky or Ike I'm
gonna I'm gonna say I don't care if
that's right or not okay so David Icke
he's the main proponent of the Reptoid
or reptilian conspiracy theory yeah now
he's a English fella he used to be a
footballer or as we would say in the
United States a soccer player yeah yeah
we'll take that football waivers to say
soccer yeah even though even girls play
even though we're the now there's a
reason why do you know why I do but I
don't know in the early nineteen
hundred's not only in England but the
United States me out there with a word
it was like code is very popular to use
acronyms for things and actually started
off with association or Football
Association I became soccer yeah oh
that's so it was
association or Football Association and
became soccer Dan all right now we had
that soccer association then later a new
sport came out we call it football
which to me it I don't know it always
seemed dumb to call American football
football because it's like yeah they
kick it sometimes but mostly you're just
like running around with today you can't
get more though yeah that's true back
when it first appeared still though when
it first appeared in the it was more
like rugby yeah I know yeah but then the
rural slightly changed and nothing this
is all NFL [ __ ] and the NFL's gonna
go out of business
it says think that people think that
that American football is American is
[ __ ] and it must go back to the 1776 or
so no it's a [ __ ] corporate invention
it's not that old well yeah a lot of
things yeah maybe I was just saying that
it makes more sense it thirty forty it
makes more sense for you know soccer as
we call it we call it football because
you basically are not allowed to pick it
up with your hands yeah it's all or your
head the hide the hot the apex of
American football was the [ __ ] 70s now
as before they had all those safety
rules and [ __ ] did you get killed [ __ ]
hurt each other really bad that's that's
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is that like they do it
now stuff although even with helmets and
stuff on nowadays is we did talk about
this what do we review - your brains
brain damage yeah even with like all
this [ __ ] equal with all the protection
on they still get [ __ ] brain damage
because you're just like whacking your
head into stuff like all days haven't
with boxers and wrestlers [ __ ] like that
- yeah somebody asked in David I just
get kicked off YouTube yeah I think he
did I think he got kicked off YouTube
and Facebook all their Twitter is still
at him because he's coming up with like
all it's not just like because of
reptilians it's because he came up with
I don't agree with any of that I [ __ ]
think anybody should be able to say you
know crazy should they want well you can
but it's like the thing about it though
is that Facebook and YouTube are private
companies and they do not have to give
you a platform yeah well you still just
I don't believe that either yeah well
I'm just saying that that's why it's not
like iterations corporations should not
be violating people's civil rights it's
like saying well we're a corporation so
you know what no we're gonna have
slavery we're a private court we will
have slavery some companies do you know
if
you'll just work here we just won't pay
you and also you have to sleep here
under the table
hopefully they reform this [ __ ] social
media is a [ __ ] utility like the
phone I think it will eventually Majan
or talking over some over the phone to
somebody back when people used phones
they don't really use them like they
used to remember remember it was like
headphones and you're talking on the
phone and then also an 18 t plus in
because we don't like you guys talking
about you guys are racist we gotta shut
this [ __ ] down imagine that well like
I'm saying I think eventually it will
get to the point where it's just like
social me will be like just has a public
utility yeah you know what I mean so I
mean it hasn't got at that point yet but
there's no choice but yeah so so David
Icke started out as a soccer player
football or whatever and he got I
believe in arthritis there's not like
that Nizhny as he couldn't play anymore
and he also used to be like a little bit
into politics he was in the Green Party
in England and Wales until they kicked
him out later on because he went batshit
crazy but for some reason in about 1991
I don't know if he just thought you know
I'm going to like make my fortune being
a famous crazy person or if something
legitimately happened to him or if you
legitimately believes this stuff I'm not
real sure but starting in about 1991 he
starts coming out with this theory that
basically every single thing like if the
whole entire population of the world is
under the control of shape-shifting
lizard people who are either aliens or
interdimensional they're kind of
interdimensional beings I think clear
about it so the thing about it is that
in you know even a stop clock is Right
twice a day yada yada now he did
actually come out and say there were
some very high-profile like British you
know politicians celebrities and stuff
like that that were involved in you know
child sexual abuse one of the people
that he says later on that he called
that was Jimmy Savile or whatever his
name is which was actually true so but
doesn't necessarily mean because he was
right about that doesn't mean that
everything else that he says doesn't
follow that everything else and he says
it's true Jo I'm just saying so he first
I think he started out with like the
whole alternative medicine thing because
of his arthritis and all this other kind
of [ __ ] and then he kind of got into you
know with like New Agers another kind of
like you know Lou Pedaler type of people
and then he started getting so like I
said this might have been like a
physical injury because he started
having these kind of like neurological
symptoms like he was started having like
um you know paralysis he started having
like hallucinations like auditory
hallucinations things like that like he
started like thinking that was like a
presence around or something like that
so he might have had some kind of you
know physical I don't know if it came
from like his sports career or if it was
like some other thing or something like
that but he was like having all these
kind of like [ __ ] that happened so he
started thinking that he was developing
psychic psychic abilities or that there
was like spirits trying to contact him
whatever then he hooks up with this
psychic and that's kind of when the
crazy started to like escalate and at
one point like the Green Party like
kicked him out because they're like look
man you're just losing it and we can't
have you around anymore
so um he got kicked out and then later
they formally banned him because they're
like yeah we just don't want you around
anymore so you think this is a mental
illness you don't think this is
something he's made of I'm not really
sure I mean it could be it could be that
he just made it up I think he's making
it up I think it's a show I mean because
there is I mean obviously if you know
what you're doing there is a lot of
money to be made yeah from coming up
with this kind of crap it's basically
because the way I saw it that listens to
him okay it's [ __ ] ridiculous
yeah this is like ridiculous but I
thought it was entertainment I thought
what he was doing was kind of like no
expand footage yeah that's how I was
taking it yeah I mean like I didn't
really think he was serious I thought it
was an entertainment
Act it's possible it could be either
saying that's how I was reading it I
mean it's it's like imagine you got
movies that are a found footage movie
right just get rid of the [ __ ] movie
go a seminar you know I mean we're a do
tells you this big long [ __ ] story
and it's kind of multimedia its
immersive and then you can kind of get
lost in this story about all the evil
people controlling the world are
actually another species of reptilian
species that straight out of II yeah and
that just was mentioned in a lot of the
stuff because that's the first thing I
thought of when I heard that I'm like
too too much is it watch me and think
that yes the documentary I don't know if
you guys know it V was back in the 80s
and I was kid it came out with a
miniseries called fiend was about it's
kind of like Independence Day and
Battlestar Galactica combined it was
[ __ ] cheesy as [ __ ] some aliens came
to earth and introduced themselves and
they said they were gonna help us it's
kind of like how to serve man that all
[ __ ] Twilight Zone movie turns out
over time you find out that they're not
people other that the skin is artificial
underneath all that they're lizards yeah
that lose my mind like when they first
pulled this get on yeah and they're
slowly taking over from within you know
at the time I didn't really know I just
thought it was a cool little series I
don't remember a whole lot about it I
don't either but looking back on it now
it was a euphemism for [ __ ] communism
and communists [ __ ] it's an
illustration because it was during the
Cold War yeah communist infiltration and
subvert and subversion mix with [ __ ]
from the Twilight Zone that's what I
thought looking back on it that's
probably what they were talking about
yeah but this sounds just like something
out of thee and when he was a lot I
thought he was talking about it that's
the that's what came to mind and I just
thought it was entertainment yeah I mean
he might just be a bullshitter because
like I said it's it said that you know
there there is a lot of coin to be made
from people who believe this [ __ ] is
real yeah if you got good enough game
and you can come up with a great and
apparently it doesn't matter you can
just come up with the craziest
should ever there is nothing that you
can come up with it is so crazy that
some idiot somewhere won't believe it
I'm gonna tell you tell you guys this
I'm drunk but this [ __ ] [ __ ] totally
true elements yeah the Tom and Jenny
show would be biggest [ __ ] it would be
big ass [ __ ] making all kinds of
money if we just came out just said all
this ships true if it wasn't for the
reptilian well yeah that's because it
breaks my heart that like you know you
see other videos like you know I'm not
saying like you know we do videos I'm
not a debunker necessarily but I don't
believe a lot of this [ __ ] it's
entertaining and I like talking about it
cuz it's funny but it's like I don't
believe reptilians are real anything but
you look at a video that's talking about
how people these people are totally
reptilians you guys and it's like they
have [ __ ] millions and that channel
has like hundreds of thousands of
subscribers and I guarantee and it does
make you cause that dude is probably got
people sending him money and sure and
it's like he's probably making a hundred
thousand I have too much of a conscience
to do that I'm not a good liar I
wouldn't be able to keep a straight face
I just wouldn't be able to I can't I
can't lie and it's like not because I
don't believe it and I would have a
really hard time like making a show
making it look like I believed it you
know what I mean I would just like crack
up and it would just I would ruin the
whole thing and then everybody would
know it's funny is that we got we okay
check this out we go to [ __ ]
somebody's you know member like Horicon
yeah Horicon we would do on BP on those
panels
yeah like Screamfest or right and that
[ __ ] would go on for [ __ ] three or
four days we'd probably do three or four
little events a day we did that twice
right for two years yeah I think we did
yeah I think it was two years each one
of those little things we did [ __ ]
we'd be lucky to have like 1520 people
in the audience listening it was very
interactive
you know it's how many people we got out
here now 54 yeah just from our home yeah
just goes to show you the effective
conventions
it's a lot cheaper lot cheaper well we
didn't pay the bill we didn't pay we
were one of the speakers we weren't the
only ones like we were on I was on a
bunch of the panel's I was at women or I
was almost yeah so a lot of books yeah
he sold like pretty much almost he's
like he's my sales guy cuz I'm not good
at that um I I think it's like I don't
like to go up to people be hey buy my
[ __ ] hey it's awesome and stuff looks
like I'm not really good at that I just
get drunk grabbing stuff yeah
hey come here Jimmy you've never met
Jenny come on BJ take pictures here a
bit yeah he's very good at that it's
like yeah just go you know cash your
credit card yeah just [ __ ] go right
in for the kill yeah we'd sell $300 for
the [ __ ] books a day yeah we sold
like all we took we sold and another
thing well we went to the convention
like I said they we they they actually
bought our passes because we were on the
panel's so we didn't have to pay to go
in we didn't have to pay for parking and
we had to pay for like all the stuff
that we took with us but we also take up
tons of booze cuz they don't really sell
booze no at the convention so everyone
just kind of brings their own like it's
sort of on the down low but not really
because everybody knows about it so we
would just bring we brought this huge
bag of like all these tiny little air
[Laughter]
[ __ ] get drunk who was the woman from
they live and yeah she was in he-man
yeah anonymous autonomous this Dan Bell
is a reptilian shapeshifters yeah yeah I
can't remember it probably like 10
minutes she was in he-man she was in
anyway she was there and the [ __ ] can I
say you wanna have a good drink and
she's like yeah she's like oh thank god
and for drinking [ __ ] she was like oh
well yeah cuz she might have been like
yo yeah I could use - because she had to
go and do all that signing yeah yeah I
mean it's like I had fun doing that but
it is it's a slog a little bit so I can
imagine if you're like somebody super
famous and you just have to like sit
down there but if you're like Tom Savini
or something like that it was so like
every one of those so it's like I can
see I've never seen him be grouchy but I
could see how he looks very gradual next
time I don't I can't blame them yeah I
mean he goes to those all the time and
everybody knows who Tom Savini is he's
living off
he always has like a huge line and you
know it's like everybody and it's like
the thing about it is that you always
have to Savini makes a couple grand a
night oh yeah because he sells the
photos someday I'll do that now um but
it's crazy I was watching this
documentary the other day I know this
were going off on a tangent of whatever
[ __ ] they just put that documentary
on shutter scream queen which was about
the guide the actor that was in front of
what he felt and I burned Allen Street -
um the one that every said Oates the
gayest movie ever made and everything
and the thing about it is that that guy
really was gay but he hadn't come out at
that time this was the 80s and it
selective height of the AIDS epidemic
and he was like afraid it's gonna ruin
his career and stuff but when that movie
came out and everybody was like woo gay
subtext and everything so it kind of
like inadvertently outed him and that
kind of like around his career and he
actually ended up having to go into
hiding like he moved to Mexico and
Slayer and he just like fell off the
radar and so after a while like
everybody's like what ever happened to
that guy like he never acted again he
never did anything so it's like finally
they tracked him down and they got him
to cut start coming out and like go to
conventions and stuff and you know he's
like it took me this long to like come
to terms with the fact that you know now
I'm famous and now everybody knows who I
am and you know and everybody wants to
talk about this movie even though the
movie ruined his career but he was like
going to meg Foster
that's right meg father's restaurant
yeah I was like mmm
yeah I got some grab jenny was right
there at the table Jess she walks up my
grab makes comments okay yeah and we had
to they made us the the moderators of
what that one that they do that that
panel that they do this just kind of
like a free-for-all like it's the most
[ __ ] up stories you can come up with
and like every justice in the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] ever and every movie and so we
brought like all the booze for that and
like we're just throwing about to people
in the audience where everybody is just
getting completely shit-faced and hard
even remember what anybody seeing that
yeah you whatever bus crash yeah which
he's told on this before but yeah that
that was like everybody was like kind of
wasted I was pretty wasted but I
remember the room beings like so quiet
yeah yeah they didn't ask us back I
think the other one for some reason I
think I rubbed some of them the wrong
way I think I don't know I never did say
but they never asked us back yeah we
went two years in a row they couldn't
sell a [ __ ] book I think I would sell
out I don't know if they got mad just
because I would sell you out every time
we were there because we sold the book
sold a lot of books they need to sell a
[ __ ] book I don't know
they were hate I didn't know if it was I
don't know there might be other reasons
why we didn't get acts back like I can
think of it I want to say because I
don't you know somebody that's kind of
well known anything about it but alright
but yeah I understand I think I know so
far yeah yeah you probably don't but
yeah so I don't know if that was the
reason right that kind of like it's not
really worth the money well yeah when do
you think about like I said when we go
if we go again I would rather just go as
a guest yeah because to be honest it's
cool to go and it's cool to like meet
because I did like run into some people
that listen to the podcast it came to
one of my things and like watch me talk
and you know some people knew who I was
and stuff but it's like
I feel like most of the time I was
either like sitting at the table selling
books or I was like unload the panels
which and I hate like talking in front
of people it makes me really nervous
so so it seemed like the whole weekend I
didn't really get to and let me walk
around and like look at other people's
stuff and we would have done better at
crime calm yeah we were a crime calm
wants us to pay well yeah it's I mean
it's really expensive I thought about it
like cuz it was supposed to be oh thank
you mark just got another donation um
thanks Laura I was actually it was
supposed to be in early May but
obviously everything got shifted I got
an email a couple days ago that they had
postponed it until I think it's the
first weekend of November maybe or end
of October early November and I kind of
wanted to do it because I have so many
like I have my you know true-crime
trilogy and everything like that um but
it's really really expensive I if I
could get in and like give a
presentation and if I gave a
presentation if they would like at least
pay the you know the fee to get in or
give me like some place to sell the
books because I mean they want at least
like 500 bucks to rent a table and then
the passes are like 120 each or
something like that so I'm already
almost up to a grand like before well
and it would be up to a grand because
I'd have to order like a stocking books
yourself um so I don't know I don't know
if it would be worth it let me sum of my
ass off and I'd have to [ __ ] be [ __ ]
I don't have to shake that crowd down
constantly to make I mean I feel like
true crime would be good because I mean
you know nonfiction if we talked about
so thank you very much Anna Leigh um
gotta look at the mic yeah well I I'm
glad but it's I'm glad that it's big
colors so I could see it thank you very
much but yes so I feel like maybe true
crime well true crime nonfiction in
general is an easier sell than fiction
because when you write fiction as good
as it is yeah people I people tend to
yeah because people tend to buy a ship
from like authors they know it's like
everybody knows Stephen King show like
that like greater [ __ ]
that's what I write if they don't know
who you are people are more reluctant to
like buy something from you cuz I'm like
what if this sucks and it's like you
know it's 15 bucks or how much it is
right and they don't want to buy some
but if something is about a subject that
you're interested in like true crime or
something like that it doesn't really oh
yeah repairable that it doesn't matter
who wrote it it just matters that you're
interested in the subject yeah you're
not selling the author you saw something
great so that is rich easier because
fiction I feel like you have to be kind
of like a personality it everybody has
to kind of know who you are before
they'll buy your fiction and really this
is something I kind of conceived a
background in sales yeah and I looked at
the problem and it was Jenny was right
in fiction when I left when I met her
and I was like I said that's a [ __ ]
risky from from from bidding on a view
of the customer
it's a risky precious because they don't
know you right you know I mean they
don't know you don't mean anybody can
tell a story you know it's so much
better when it's about something that
actually happened yeah because I also
you're interested see and then they'll
come back to the author yeah get out of
me so you're still working you're still
selling a book it's just it's not
fiction it's just not and I'm still
writing about [ __ ] that I like because
I'm [ __ ] fascinated by true crime and
I've read about it all day long like you
know what I mean if even if I wasn't
writing about it so it's not like I'm
just like writing about [ __ ] just to
make money or whatever it is something
I'm interested in it was something that
I considered doing before the era of the
Stephen King's is gone that came from a
time when the industry was very
different now you know digital media and
internet access and everything competes
against everything else non-fiction is
the way to go well and honestly the
fiction that does sell and I'm not you
know it really seems like a lot of
fiction that goes [ __ ] viral that
every is it's like [ __ ] like Twilight yo
and eco hey Anika what's up thank you
very much so you know it's there are
still like authors that make like a [ __ ]
ton of money but a lot of times it's
just it's not good a lot of and I feel
like this is probably like going back a
few years but a lot of it was like
young adults that's why there's like so
much especially after like Harry pile
the Harry Potter series came out there
was like a huge explosion in like young
adult books and pretty much if you wrote
like a fantasy series like with young
adults in it like geared toward that age
group um you could pretty much like
writer and ticket because like people
were looking for the next Harry Potter
you know I mean so there were like a ton
there was a ton of [ __ ] that came out in
the wake of that that like made [ __ ]
tons of money and the same thing was
like [ __ ] you know like I said
Twilight fifty Shades of Grey like all
that kind of crap which is terribly
written but I guess it doesn't matter I
can even get through the whole book it's
like I read like a page and I was like
okay whatever but yeah so yes so we're
talking about David I carry yeah go back
so yeah so David Ickes theory is kind of
what they would call a grand unified
conspiracy theory in that it kind of
like folds in a whole bunch of other
conspiracy theories because his whole
thing with the lizard people is that the
lizard people is basically like
everything like everybody that's an
elite or whatever is like in power
whether they're like a scientist or
they're in the media or whatever they're
pretty much all lizard people you know
and I mean anybody that has any power is
a lizard person so there's all just this
all ties in with the Illuminati it all
ties in with new order new world order
the UN Bilderberg Group trilateral
commission all that kind of stuff all
lizard people now so he wrote a book in
1999 called the biggest secret and in
this book he specified that the lizard
people or reptilians or Reptoids were
from there interdimensional they can
shape-shift into people there are some
people that are like on earth now that
are like half lizard half person and I
guess there's a weird thing too because
I think later he said that well the
people the lizards can shape-shift into
humans but then there's also like humans
that are from that same lineage but they
can't shape-shift into lizards unless
the lizards like possess them or
something I'm not real
Claire on it and probably he isn't
either thank you again Matt if they're
asking to make somebody a moderator to
keep the box out Michael would you
Michael Ventris would you like to be a
moderator who were ya I don't see any
buds but I'm trying to way I'm looking
at my notes so I'm not like look at this
you're looking at it Morgan but yeah I
mean you pretty much says okay so he
says they're interdimensional aliens
essentially they come from a rift in the
space-time continuum near the
constellation Draco make a comma box la
moderator
wait how do I do that do his name click
his name from I'm afraid to point at
plan I'm afraid to do his name is right
right there yeah and then what is this
every year and I do the same thing for
Michael Ventris right there yeah I got
it I got it Michael you're now moderator
all right so we have two oh my goodness
Wow
Mary name she's one of our patrons shows
I would totally donate to you guys but I
just got a new puppy and found out I'm
pregnant
congratulations make her a moderate
congratulations - shoot do you want to
be a moderator congratulations on the
pregnancy many people are saying that
David Icke actually because of his
ex-wife said he actually does believe
his theories and then he's super
paranoid yeah I do kind of feel like he
he got on the crazy train and once you
get on that crazy train I feel like it's
kind of get off especially when you go I
mean he's gone all on into crazy day
it's not just like a little kind of
thing that's like oh you know he's way
past abducted by aliens this is way past
Bigfoot this is way past I've seen his
product I didn't think he was serious
but now that people are saying that oh
no no he believes this [ __ ] that
[ __ ] bad
[ __ ] crazy you'd have to be [ __ ]
batshit crazy to believe that that's V
that's what I think that that's where
like he maybe saw thee and got that he
saw it somebody thought that it was like
no one mentioned that he had a book
called [ __ ] the reptilians and the
Jews so there was something about what
Jillian's in the Jews are here she's
very um okay so he has been dogged
rightfully so thank you very much in LA
hey-oh signing off you got Oh we'll be
put out in a couple days you watch a
rest yeah we're just gonna put it up
like either immediately or like tomorrow
morning it should just go right up yeah
he has been dogged pretty much his whole
career of anti-semitism because you know
he's basically saying he uses like a lot
of coded kind of dog whistle kind of
words that you know kind of need you
yeah and so he's his defense is that I'm
not talking about real Jews I'm talking
about reptilians who are pretending to
be okay but yeah so he also like and I'm
sure he got this from zecharia sitchin
but he is saying that these reptilians
or aliens or interdimensional beings or
whatever are Anunnaki just like Zachary
said we did like a whole show about that
didn't yeah and I had been interbreeding
with humans you know throughout recorded
history
now the stupid thing about this I don't
know where he came up with this [ __ ]
like I said other than him seeing V and
forgetting that it was like a fictional
TV show and just thinking that it was a
dream or a vision that he had and it was
real but people that actually believe in
this [ __ ] because apparently there
aren't they're splatter Thursday you
guys which you know a lot of flat
earthers are joking I hope so yeah
because you know it's easy to prove that
the earth is round okay so that's what
they want you to it's a lot and I see
some guys make some videos that prove
that it's flat they're [ __ ] genius
you got to be real smart to prove that
the world is flat so yes I swear that no
one's ever done it
like how do you how do you illustrate
the fact that the Sun sets and rises so
you have to [ __ ] come up with a new
model yeah no need to explain like I
mean I've come up with a hold of because
it's just kind of like people that are
like evolution deniers yes um they don't
realize that just denying evolution or
trying to come up with some little dough
Bamba your beetle or whatever the [ __ ]
the little stories they come up with
that's not enough to say that evolution
did it happen you need to debunk a huge
you gotta come
serious biological sciences physics you
know [ __ ] you know there's a huge
huge like kilos of science that you have
to debug if evolution doesn't exist and
how the [ __ ] you explained the banana
because the banana didn't come from
nature came from selective breeding
which is very very funny to me because
he was that nutcase creationist there
and he said that God made because
rounded so therefore yummy yeah
the original banana was fruit he was
straight at about two and a half two
inches long and didn't taste good
yeah and that was within human we didn't
win that was like modern human history
yeah you know so we did the same thing
with the church selectively breed with
you like corn on the cob is that started
out as like a wheat type graphical I
think it's called teosinte or something
like that and we bred it right to look
like that through selective breeding
yeah well we got caught of aztlán in
here Mandy of the ultimate [ __ ]
Mesoamerican deep in the heart of
[ __ ] Tijuana okay he will tell you
that [ __ ] corn all right that when
people first saw the corn glyph in the
[ __ ] Mayan and Aztec language they
said that could never be corn that
doesn't look like [ __ ] car of course
it was corn man the original corn was
only about that yeah it looked almost
like a wheat stock like a little wheat
stock it is like a little [ __ ] oval
with little corn kernels saying that's
all it was like a little oval yeah
that's the way the corn really was
that was old-school Mexican car
marvelous [ __ ] thing and Europeans and
Middle Easterners do not like corn
because they're just not [ __ ]
civilized corn you know no I got to tell
you this and maybe it's the thing in
Asia to when I was in the UK they don't
think I know this is what I'm gonna tell
you right now I was in the UK and they
have like frozen pizzas and they had
like a normal one that's like the normal
pepperoni and cheese and all the other
guy stuff they had one that had corn
niblets on it and I was just kind of
like what and I've heard from like
people I know that they live in Japan
that they had that that's a big thing in
Japan too that you click or nipples I'm
like he's in the chow hall one time and
[ __ ] that's crazy I was in a chow hall
one time in a military situation that's
a bunch of Middle Easterners [ __ ] they
were there for training and [ __ ] when
they saw that we were serving corn they
were outraged this would they would eat
that [ __ ] I don't know it's just a bit
they just oh that's for cows as for
cattle well even cows aren't supposed to
eat it they just give it to them over
here because it fattens them up quicker
I'm getting into that down into that dim
mist a Maseca
[ __ ] corn meal to make the meat core
tortillas yeah and making tamales I
gotta get back on that tamale yeah we
need to get back on that's gonna be in
the cookbook to how to make [ __ ] this
is gonna be the world's most giant it's
not gonna be giant how to make corn
tortillas on how to make how to make
tamales yeah I could make it tamale pie
so you have to do I work for happening
but I'm gonna know how to wrap it too
big didn't lacs paper cuz I don't have
the corn husks yeah but now when I made
those tortillas I didn't have a press so
the shape wasn't that right before they
were sure much they were a lot better
the difference do you know a homemade
tortilla corn tortilla a store-bought
tortilla advanced night and day yeah
it's night and day
well that's kind of true that yeah and
the flavors so much better yes
so he says sweet corn is good at
anything right now pizza I didn't try it
I just thought it was super weird I mean
like I can't judge because I really like
shrimp pizza and I like which I know a
lot of people don't like like I like I
said I hang out like on a lot of food
blogs and stuff like that and apparently
liking pineapple on pizza is like a food
heresy just kind of like putting ketchup
on hot dogs which I also like so fight
me I know you're not supposed to we'll
be in December for hours I know we've
already been like two hours yeah but
yeah what what saying is that it seems
like a lot of the evidence and I'm
putting the bunny rabbit ears of this
supposed everyone in power as a reptile
type of thing is pretty much I don't
know it seems like he's always putting
up pictures of like celebrities or
politicians or something and they'll be
making like a weird expression or
they'll have red eye like from a camera
flash yes therefore though but yet which
to me just seems um I'm just gonna say
that seems like a little bit slim yeah
as evidence goes the only thing that
upsets me about the whole David I think
is that you have pedestrians okay we're
talking about just [ __ ] noobs to the
situation when they [ __ ] mention Alex
Jones
they also said Oh lizard people there's
a difference between Alex Jones he's
crazy in a different way he has other
crazy conspiracy theories not the
reptilian you know
AJ AJ is a brilliant performer it's like
performance art it's infotainment taken
to noon and he sometimes drives me
[ __ ] nuts especially when he doesn't
have any material like he's got nothing
really new to say teddy just like even
when I ask for a [ __ ] hour over like
one subject I would hi everybody
I would put a fast-forward it on a slow
day you gotta fast forward it to where
the guests are oh you think he'd be at
this point
you'd think he'd be a student up to at
least make up something entertaining
we know he actually he's just kidding
you can't see him on YouTube anymore you
got to go on you got to go on [ __ ]
shoot to see or he has his own platform
- oh if it's Emily Infowars platform his
guests are more interesting than him but
he's the entertainer you know I mean
that's the way I see it I'm mostly
mostly watch that - just see what the
guests are gonna say cuz he's got some
good ones yeah well he's just an
entertainer you know man it's like
infotainment for some reason like I said
even though we do a podcast like for
some reason I have a hard time listening
to them myself because like I said it's
the same reason I can't really listen to
audiobooks like I know a lot of people
like audiobooks cuz you can listen to
them on your commute and stuff but it's
like when I try to listen to an
audiobook especially if I'm doing
something else like if I'm you know
doing some graphic design work or
something that I put someone in
background I will just completely spaced
out and like not even hear what it's
saying you know what I mean because it's
like I always prefer to like read things
and like read books and her if I'm going
to watch a movie which has a visual and
an auditory component like if something
just has an auditory component then I'll
either fall asleep or my mind will
wander and I'll just like 20 minutes
later and I'll have no idea what the
person said because I just hand them out
so you know I mean so I have a hard time
like listening to that but yeah so it
really does seem like that's the only
like evidence that he has it's like all
these pictures of like you know it's
like oh look they're shape-shifting like
[ __ ] up for a second and we saw their
true form like because it was like a red
eye or it was like they made like a
weird lizard eat face or some [ __ ] and
he had like all these [ __ ] I had it
up on this frame over here but it shut
off he had like all these kind of like
ways to tell if you're a reptilian and
according to that like I don't know how
many you have to like check off of this
checklist before you originally or not
but I was at least four of those so you
heard it here first I could be a
reptilian and not even know about that
[ __ ] because one of the things is for
some reason if you have like reddish
hair like red hair which I do
I know you can't tell but my natural
hair color is red also if you have
really low blood pressure um if you're
really into science like it's all those
kind of things like if you have like
blue or haze or green or hazel eyes that
kind of like change color like a
chameleons eyes if you can affect
electrical appliances RF psychic or
something like that then that means your
reptilian now pretty much everybody I
think he is accused like the British
royal family I think were the first ones
that he accused of being like
particularly like Queen Elizabeth or you
know but um you know that she's like
some High Priestess of satanic lizardy
whatever but pretty much everybody in
the British royal family is one pretty
much every president Republican or
Democrat is also a reptilian and then
he's got like weird [ __ ] random ones
in there like some celebrities and stuff
and like I said I think I mentioned this
on one of the other shows but one video
that I saw that was pointing out
celebrities to her tail hands they had
this [ __ ] footage of mmm and it was I
can't remember one of those shows on MTV
I can't remember the name of it but they
where they like interview people or
whatever and he was like kind of
standing of the two of the other people
were talking and said no one was talking
to Eminem at the moment and so Eminem
was just kind of like spacing out or
just like staring at the camera and like
looking like super high and so that was
the clip that they used like to prove
that he was erect Chile and just because
he had totally spaced and like [ __ ] up
and everything so that was kind of like
[ __ ] so the fact that that's kind of
like all the proof that they need is
they just these videos have they just
have these clips of celebrities making
weird expressions or you know and
they'll take like witnesses because I
think they have like a couple people
that said that they hung out with the
first George Bush George HW and it's
like oh his shape-shifting like messed
up for a second we saw like the lizard
person and you know and also their kind
of stuff so it's it's just very very you
know slim like I said that's kind of
like the only thing that he has like to
point
it's just these like stupid photos and
like I said he does have he's also gone
in for other conspiracy theories too
like I said the whole you know he's
known as being kind of anti-semitic even
though he denies it but a lot of the
[ __ ] that he says but you can't be
against the Jews from all those Jews or
lizards I'm not talking about actual
dude they're not real they're lizards
for it's like I'm like [ __ ] seriously
come on that's like that's it's just I
don't know and he's into like some other
because the the number one thing that is
that means that you will believe in
conspiracy theories is if you believe in
another one because people that believe
in one conspiracy theory tend to believe
in a bunch of other ones rational wiki
calls it crank magnetism because it's
like people are attracted to like a
whole bunch of conspiracy theories like
and what like yeah yeah there's the UFO
prosser was saying welcome back to the
same theme from v-- yeah weird
lizards that come out of UF people in
the streamer saying that they're doing
the Alex Jones is also Bill Hicks
concept I have heard that although that
he's pulling um yeah they chant anaconda
man but I looked into it no it's not
they actually have pictures I heard that
he was Andy Kaufman but Andy Kaufman's
been gone for a long time yeah you know
there are Mighty Mouse yeah there are
pictures of Bill Hicks and Alex Jones
during the same time period and that
they look different yeah I do look the
same I can see it they do what is it a
similar book and I have heard that but
like I said the first thing I heard was
him and Auntie poppin like he was a
performance artist by oh thank you Janet
Lana
Jonna blonde afire or whatever I can't
say it upside down well I'm not that
drunk I'm just getting a spa where I
can't really
yes she's one of our patrons as well so
yes so not only his he into like all
this kind of like alternative medicine
[ __ ] like David Icke and the
reptilians he's also into Holocaust
denial that's fun you know so you know
so all these people that say oh he's not
handsome but I can't everything like
that I should note that in 2019 he wrote
a book called the trigger the lie that
changed the world who really did it and
why which blamed 9/11 on the Jews except
I really do reptilians but they're
lizard juice they're just it's like yeah
he's into like heats of vaccine denial
aids denial water fluoridation blah blah
blah
it's like pretty much every conspiracy
you can think of like everything he's in
on that [ __ ] cuz like I said that is
very very common in conspiracy thinking
if you believe one you tend to believe
like a bunch of other ones that are like
related conspiracy the conspiracy scene
is kind of a what's a good way to put a
spectrum okay there's actual stuff that
really did happen that can be
historically proven kind of like the
conspiracy stuff and the [ __ ] fake
polish attacks on Germany digression
yeah oh yeah there are are real that
happened there's things that
intelligence agencies did things that
think you solve Hernandez thank you very
much they're much awesome there there's
the it ranges from that the things that
could have happened things that do seem
to be happening duper typical itical
groups go on all the way to the [ __ ]
dam delusional that there's no way that
could that's what I mean and that's
spectrum that's what's shitty about it
is that if you feel like because you
can't like just Kurt blog say like
conspiracy theories they're always like
yeah thank you very much Matt um
you can't like carte blanche say oh all
conspiracy theories are [ __ ] because
that is obviously not the case there are
one so you know look at like [ __ ]
it's like water Gator COINTELPRO or you
know the fact that the [ __ ] FDA ultra
yeah
cultural areas like the CIA is like look
at the Tuskegee flick experiments all
there is syphilis experiments all that
guy stuff this [ __ ] does happen so it's
it sucks that it in a way it sucks that
it happens because the fact that that
happens means that you can go crazier
crazier crazier larger larger larger and
people will still kind of believe it
because they've already kind of sowed
mistrust for these smaller conspiracies
so you can get people to believe in
larger line it's a process called going
down the rabbit hole yeah
sometimes you can go down the goddamn
rat hole all right but you got it you
got to stop yourself at some point
conspiracies happen to achieve something
tangible you're talking about things
like alien creatures that are reptiles
that come from another planet they're
coming here from UFOs that [ __ ] that you
you need to get locked up and thrown
into a pet cell do you actually believe
that's not what yeah okay and yeah
that's not benefiting human beings well
that's one thing do you have to think
about it like I said with conspiracy
theories that they know actually happens
if it's like my Watergate or something
like that you have to think to yourself
one this was a fairly small conspiracy
there was only you know a relatively
small number of people it was only a
secret for a relatively short time you
know and someone benefited from it or
someone thought they were gonna benefit
from it at some point when you get into
these bigger world-spanning like you
know let's say that for the sake of
argument let's say that the whole
British royal family all the president
said let's say those were lizra P if
they're interdimensional you know alien
beings or whatever okay well then now
what like now what do we do about that
you know what I mean it's like who
benefits from knowing that it's like why
you benefiting from like you know what
are we going to do about it then here's
another thing that's kind of related to
that all the rich people the royal
families the the child Island man
okay they're all getting blood
transfusions from pubescent children
there is some evidence that there were
companies that were doing that which di
do is is they just drain blood out of a
kid that's going through puberty they
paid the kid
damn five hundred dollars a liter and
they sell that to rich people they put
it into their [ __ ] Bloods and we see
I can but I don't know if that's
happening but I could buy that that's
not yeah that's not gonna happen that's
not that's not that crazy it is
happening and it's been happening for
long even mentioned it in death becomes
her they did yet and evidently that was
that evidently there were some companies
run by small amounts of doctors that did
that for very wealthy people in their
homes and we're doing it in the hospital
and it was hush-hush not illegal just
weird yeah that they're basically no
they're not killing any okay they're
just giving somebody a blood they're
very taking blood they're paying
somebody yeah they're buying very high
quality blood from yeah kids going
through puberty and putting that into
old people and taking the old people's
blood out it's called a transfusion it's
easy to do they've been doing that kind
of [ __ ] since the late eighteen colors
music well why why would you do that a
kid of that age produces very high
quality blood it has something Seth says
I'm just here to get a shout out
okay so we're shouting out we're sorry I
had to like it produces very high
quality blood and when they're going
through puberty there's also things in
that blood like the hormones that can
act kinda like a hormone replacement
therapy it could is it's it's it's maybe
okay it's plausible that that blood will
end up in some inside somebody's dog
bone marrow and might influence a
person's blown bone marrow to produce a
little bit better quality blood we know
that rich people live a long [ __ ] time
that might be because well in general
they get better medical care they have
access to [ __ ]
treatments that poor people cannot
afford yeah okay and this seems to be
one of them okay sounds sinister but
very legal legal
now there's another variation of this
same story another donation of Tom takes
off his shirt
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
another version of that story that
they're taking children and torturing
them to to extract from the pituitary
glands adrenochrome I don't know if
that's true
- harder - that's a kid man that would
be harder to cover up the first time
this just mentioned was in that damn
remember that [ __ ] was it even Las
Vegas yeah it was named yet fairy living
las yeah Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas
that was a drug that he kind of made he
mentioned that Satanist
tell him sold him adrenochrome from the
pituitary class of children I think
that's where that came from
yeah well that's what I mean it's like
some of these things like the whole [ __ ]
about the Illuminati thank you David Jun
the man you're 64 I'm becoming like a
gaggle early next time we're gonna have
to put you in some chaps and you
sous-chef some [ __ ] leather [ __ ]
[ __ ] and a damn [ __ ] a riding crop
good up here
break it would bring Toby over here
they have [ __ ] like bondage day that
would be very entertaining okay now okay
now that's an extreme version of that
tale this pituitary gland adrenochrome
story I think they came from Hunter s
Thompson well and some of that stuff
about like pituitary like [ __ ] from the
pituitary gland that came from like old
like old 50s movies I think there was
some [ __ ] thank you very much I'm a
shrew only get 10 Canadian for sure next
thing you know they help me take my
pants off and [ __ ] that'll be the next
thing like I said I really like I said
you're gonna have to work yeah to be
terrible so [ __ ] a be a [ __ ] aviator
sunglasses and a [ __ ] is pre-star yeah
oh my god you see a bride and I was
gonna go here to rob halford costume
anyway she was I was gonna get a Rob you
could ride into the room on your boat on
a motorcycle I don't know how they would
love this you would [ __ ] the carpet I
didn't know I've built a motorcycle yeah
Zach says we'll have to move the show to
ChatterBait soon they're asking me to
take my shirt off to study you well I'm
not guys boobs that's kind of like I had
I had a friend that used to call me tits
McGee yeah I remember yeah yeah
how does he got that from somewhere but
yeah I can't but yeah so another thing
Oh another thing that David Icke did to
like other than all his other
shenanigans and like all other stupid
[ __ ] that he believes he also went
around saying that he was the son of the
Godhead like you know and for a time he
wore nothing but turquoise her he
stopped dreaming yeah it's taking us
back to the [ __ ] which is really weird
because I any advice I remember like I
used to work in a record store back in
the 90s and the manager were nothing but
purple I don't know what her deal is
with it but yeah so so I mean in the UK
as far as I know like from everything
that I've heard um everyone just thought
he was like a laughingstock like even
his family would get laughed at like
when his wife and [ __ ] like they would
just be like hey you're married to that
like that's very good
but I did note that and I don't know how
true that is but according to Gallup
polls in the United States they asked
about various conspiracy theories and
superstitions and things like that four
percent of the American population admit
that they believe that people in power
are all reptilians now I will note that
okay so I don't know how many of that
four percent because that's a lot of
people y'all like cuz this how many
people live in the I say three hundred
fifty million something like that it's a
lot so four percent it sounds like not
that much but that's a pretty
significant percentage like way more
than people that should legitimately who
believing in reptilians um now I don't
know if some of those people are just
like trolling and they're just like
saying yeah I totally balloon actually
just be funny but you have to think to
that some people might believe in
reptilians but I don't want to tell a
pollster that because they're like
ashamed of it so I think it probably
evens out so I think probably four
percent is about right which is four
percent too many people to be believing
that the world is run by shape-shifting
aliens I'm just saying you know that's
just my opinion I mean four percent oh
oh and also this is good too so David I
also said and I think somebody brought
this up on the on the chat here that he
was on there's a
talk-show over there I think his name's
Terry Wogan or whatever and he
interviewed David Icke and he was like
kind of mean to him but you know I I can
see why probably rightly so but I guess
he apologized for it later on because he
thought he was like too mean or whatever
but they had like you know the press in
the UK is kind of like probably more
invasive than their in the u.s. they'll
like hang out on your yard and [ __ ] like
that so they did that a lot with David
Icke but also he also said in 2012 when
they had the Olympics in London that
year he said that the opening ceremony
that they had in London was a satanic
ritual that was supposed to harness
negative energy and that the stadium for
the Olympics was put in that particular
place because it was harnessing the
power from the earth energy grid and
they were tapping into the power from
like Glastonbury Tor which is kind of
like supposed to be some big like like
circle of like psych power or whatever
um so yeah he said that as well so I'm
not really I don't know like he really
does seem to believe this [ __ ] I mean
gotta believe it and he goes and he also
believes that like the matrix is like
real like we live in a holographic
projection type of thing which maybe we
do but I feel like that I feel like
that's not falsifiable like even like if
we do how would we prove it he's
delusional that's that's kind of a
problem that I not with a lot of
conspiracy theories too is that they're
not falsifiable meaning that even if you
like present like if you meet a flat
earther for example and you give them
all these examples like evidence that
it's like look this is how what evidence
we have in ther earth is round is that
the other and it's like everything you
say to them they just have some other
like explanation for it oh well you're
just a shell or NASA you know faked that
or so so if there's no evidence that
will convince them that they are wrong
then what is the point of talking with
them because the theory that they have
is not based on
facts are logic it's based on what they
feel to be true it's based on their
emotions do you want another drink
yeah sure all right so yeah
so that was another thing that I was cuz
I was like watching all these like
psychological because I'm kind of
fascinated about I'm not a real big um
you know conspiracy theory proponent I'm
not a real big I'm very like rational
very skeptical or if it's like it takes
me a lot for me to like believe
something and so I do feel like there's
a particular emotional need that is met
by a lot of these and I do feel like
that if you have a theory about
something that the world is run by
reptilians or whatever then if you don't
have any evidence to back that up and if
people give you evidence to the contrary
and you just don't want to hear it or
everything that you show them they just
say oh it's faked or you must be paid by
whoever like NASA is paying you the
government is paying you to say that or
you fell for it or blah blah then I
don't really know if there's like any
point in arguing with people like that
because they can't because they didn't
come to the theory using reason or using
logic or and so I don't know if you can
reason or logic them out of it because
it's like obviously filling an emotional
need for them so I don't know how
productive it would be to like argue
with them because I feel like anything
you say is just going to be dismissed
and if there's nothing that you can say
to convince them that they're wrong then
I you know I don't know I just feel like
it's pointless talking to people like
that and I don't really like to do
pointless things so I don't know and I
don't know it the whole kind of thing
makes me mad because I don't know I did
I do feel like because you know David
Icke is another one that you know more
recently was a proponent of the whole
like 5g cause we're in a virus which are
now the [ __ ] that works but whatever and
I think that was one of the things that
got kind of got him kicked off some of
the platforms it was his because you
know they've been cracking down on like
misinformation about current of IRA so
it's kind of like a big deal so I do
feel like that was kind of like the
impetus for finally like
him off certain platforms because he was
spreading like a lot of this dangerous
misinformation which you know I can
understand that it's understandable I do
understand why people believe particular
things but I do think that it's more an
emotional lead rather than them coming
to I don't know I you know I think it's
good it's natural and it's good to be
distrustful of you know particularly
stories that come from like you know
powerful people why they do particular
things it's good to have a certain
amount of skepticism about that it's
good to mistrust the government to a
certain extent but you know only up to a
point I think after a point you're just
kind of going off the rails into crazy
town you're just like coming up with all
this crazy [ __ ] and the fact that people
like David Icke have followers it's what
that there are some people that
legitimately believe that evolution
didn't happen there's some people that
legitimately believe that the earth is
flat you know I know it's not a lot of
people but it's enough people that it's
like kind of alarming because it seems
like there's nothing that you could come
up with that was nutty enough that
somebody will not actually legitimately
believe it and then once you get on it
particularly when you get on like
YouTube or you get on some other even
you know Google or so that once you
start going down that certain path it
kind of like it knows your preferences
so it's just going to show you more
things that back up that worldview and
then you have the whole confirmation
bias thing going on and you start seeing
less and less things that are not you
know showing you like a counterpoint to
like what you believe and I think that
that's kind of like bad to you because
you get on a particular path and then
you're not seeing anything that
contradicts what you believe in because
I mean I've seen that happen to like
particularly on YouTube because it has
the whole suggested videos you know I'll
you know all my suggested videos are
true crime and horror stuff because
that's like all I watch but if you get
into like political stuff like on
YouTube it's gonna know like what your
preferences are so I'm just gonna show
you stuff that's you know already kind
of like agreeing with what you already
believe in so you're not going to see
anything
from the other side and I think that
happens with a lot of conspiracy
theories too and you know like I said
that's kind of why even though when I
was researching this show I really went
to rational wiki first and then I was
kind of like kind of going from there
because I didn't want to just dive deep
down into like the crazy [ __ ] on YouTube
about like blizzard people and stuff
because I mean I don't know I I just
can't I just can't get into the catch
I just I'm such a sceptical person and
I'm just so I have a really low
tolerance for [ __ ] in general and I
can't really watch it and then I don't
and then I feel like the more [ __ ] like
that I watch like the more they're gonna
recommend to me and then my whole
recommended feed is just gonna be like
full of [ __ ] and it's just gonna be
like really tiresome Sara just get
really really mad about it yeah and yeah
exactly like minute Nicole just said you
start seeing everything through that
lens and I think that's like a really
dangerous thing to be doing because you
kind of like get you know your mind gets
put on like one track and then you just
keep going down that track and then and
like I said confirmation bias it's a
very it's a known thing it's like it's
very very easy to do everybody does it
it's just like it's a natural way that
your brain goes you naturally want to
listen to things that are agree with
what you already think and you downplay
things that don't agree with that so I
do feel like that's something that you
always have to like look out for that
you're not falling victim to that
because everyone does and it's a really
natural proclivity and I think that's
like a problem that a lot of conspiracy
theorists and particularly fall into
because once you get on that path it's
just gonna keep leading you down that
same thing and you're just going to keep
watching these videos that say this and
the other thing and the more you watch
videos like that the less you watch
videos that are like you know hey maybe
that's [ __ ] or there's no evidence
for that or whatever and you're just
gonna keep going down that thing and
then you just end up believin like the
craziest [ __ ] ever it's like the Frog
that's in the boiling water it's like
it's almost like it happens without you
being aware of it you know what I mean
oh he's coming back to the tricks look
you still in front she's outside yeah
she won't come in you need to take a
break there anything I can to him oh
really okay yeah sure let this woman
take
great see what's going on with everybody
I know because I've been like she's been
sitting there at that desk for [ __ ]
an hour almost two hours I'm well I've
been sitting at this desk since like
morning you know I'm talking about
during the livestream another one you
got so many of them okay all right
everybody what's going on here
Tom 20 20
ayahuasca in a livestream in that right
as long mr. Khan
doing Dennis shirtless huh man [ __ ] you
people doing dinner gotta read what
everybody's saying hold on I'm gonna run
as the [ __ ] US president as a leather
daddy then I got people telling me to
fix up the RV 350 okay oh she's back
already
damn I thought I was gonna have to
[ __ ] entertain for a long time Alex
Jones is a well-fed reptile he's a well
man he is certainly well fed I I didn't
believe he's a reptilian I don't know
about other people got people saying I'm
not as buff as they thought I was first
off it take you don't even [ __ ]
scratch the surface until you've been
lifting for five years I've only been
lifted for two and I'm nearly 51 years
so I can oh all right you would never
look good as me at 51 Tammy says my cat
is an alien aliens do you remember that
movie they just won his old memories is
crazy old like live-action Disney movies
they did like back in the 70s and early
eighties that were um let's see what was
it called cat from outer space it was
like a little cat that came in a little
spaceship I remember seeing that in the
theater
I must been really little and I remember
sitting in the very front row and like
pretending I was a cat because I was
like and I was like so excited to be at
the movie theater and I was in the front
row and there's like a big gap between
the front row screaming sounds like me
and my little cousin were like crawling
around like pretend we were cats and
[ __ ] I don't know I just remember that
but yet so other than Tom and Jenny who
has shrunk me so many people who said I
have sexual problems oh [ __ ]
because of what this is gonna die I need
to plug in Oh No
go get your charger you I can't believe
you didn't bring that got say he just
like he camera getting old sucks you
guys to reptilians have sexual problems
probably I would imagine um how do we
wait
Tourette tumbles even they do it
[Laughter]
actually it's funny I was coming back
from my formal walk the other day
probably like a couple days ago we have
you know we have those little annals or
whatever they call them those little
bitty lizards like all like all over the
place in Florida and they're always you
know lizards don't have any shame so
they'll just like have sex right there
in front of the right everybody so I saw
a couple of them we did a long
explanation of what I mean it's pretty
self-explanatory but they came from a
particular blood working about a video
game called rest and we had back in the
80s you play that [ __ ] up at 7/11 it was
a Conan rip off its kind of like ghosts
and goblins you [ __ ] jump through it
there was a time where you there's one
part of the game when you'd fall down
these pits and they say have these
spikes at the bottom of the pits yeah
and it always looked like a hitch in the
ass I was like that's how we imagine
anal penetration all right
then it would go well like I said I kind
of feel like that's probably the if you
fell on a huge spike but first that
probably approximates the sound that you
and me oh oh my god people talking about
they're feeling good they're drinking
straw Tammy's drinking strawberry
margaritas cool ooh that sounds
delicious
all right erectile disfunction man 900
Cole's talking about laying
yeah like I said I saw I saw two lizards
humping just the other day
also when I was out for a while problems
coming up a lot yeah I think I forgot to
mention but like I saw two Cardinals
humping yeah like just right and a
little bit half I was like you guys get
a room zach is saying to him and his hot
Jewish boyfriend would love to see me oh
[Laughter]
my god yeah
Rast and people remember rest in yeah I
asked my Sega Master System
no actually ZX spectrum he said yeah
brass Dan came out on home systems later
it actually originally was a [ __ ]
sitar came as an arcade game as a
console I remember it was [ __ ] good
it's day yesterday that was at the same
time it's around the same time that God
that was out spy higher and ghosts and
goblins it was around that time I kind
of remember like you showed it to me it
looked pretty familiar I was playing a
lot of arcade games around that yeah I
was like super into like I don't know I
like the weird ones like joust and
burger tenements do me and [ __ ] me
and [ __ ] nothing did me to call stud
because he couldn't get laid so called
stud okay yeah and Jason me and Jason
will go down plate one called Ikari
warriors Cory warriors was badass
they had a joystick that you could turn
360 degrees in a couple different fire
buttons and it was to Rambo's one of
them with a red headband and up with a
blue headband Rambo run through this
thing to scroll by and all these [ __ ]
aliens to come and get you statues and
alien statues and had these things we
called simply DS gonna call them seen we
say so it's like Zimbabwe but no say
bleep easy DS raloo some of the little a
these little tiny little green munchkins
they look like little bitty green little
green Michelin men and they would run at
you at a huge [ __ ] swarms and [ __ ]
when you kill them they'd make a sound
that kind of sound like simply beat when
they would die hold back swarms of them
you had to make sure that you could
complain those before those things came
you can see it I [ __ ] I was missing
Ikari warriors one one time really
hardcore and I looked on YouTube and
somebody has a video of them of the
screen going through the entire game of
Ikari warriors see what a time to be
alive the time to be alive and I was
just [ __ ] sitting back enjoying it
like I was back in 1986 at the arcade
and we had spent like 40 bucks to get
through that [ __ ] because if you have
enough money you can get there because
it was able to continue yeah and you're
constantly continue during the time of
space harrier this is long before you
[ __ ] were even born okay
they talk about all these [ __ ] video
games and the video games of the day are
[ __ ] easy compared to the video games
that we grew up with back and back in my
day those [ __ ] were two dimensional
two dimensional entities you're imagine
well not only you had to have perfect
[ __ ] timing well yeah also you had to
use all your orders
you only have any quarters and you
didn't get to like they were totally
unforgiving
yeah totally unforgiving that's all i'ma
say they were very frustrating I
remember when we first got like I was
really an arcade game stuff but it's
like we got like the home consoles like
I said I think I mentioned this before
we had like [ __ ] knockout [ __ ] like
with the Odyssey and like the Tandy [ __ ]
from Radio Shack or whatever we did
actually get um a Nintendo later and
then we got a Sega so we have like one
of the other but it's like I remember
like I was into some of the games I
liked Castlevania I like Zelda I liked
all that stuff my brother and Tetris I
love sacher's but um so my brother would
play them and he got like he got like
you guys he got like super super into it
yeah and it's like what something bad
haven't ever died or something he would
have like a [ __ ] meltdown man he'd be
like they're banging on the floor throw
in the controller and like all this I'd
be like dude
they're asking what kind of worries it's
a eek Akari I must spell it okay hold
position
I love I think it was called Akari
this is my spell I don't put it in the
comment section Ikari warriors I think
this I know when to hold on it might
have been a I would thought it was a k
RI RI r was a to kaiser one I can't
remember I think it might be this so I I
Akari a courier a k a yeah first but I
put it in there again Ikari warriors I
think that's what's called okay I mean I
was a kid pulling this [ __ ] out of my
medulla oblongata long time for its
there were two youth centers so you're
wrestling yeah yeah we're just trying to
that's how I remember it was either an A
or an i but it started I teal warriors
that would be funny yeah like being
thrown like Swedish meatball into people
and like parts of bookshelves and [ __ ]
like that
I saw this back there you can see that
game on YouTube yeah well like I said
you can see everything I'm doing YouTube
nowadays it's really funny because [ __ ]
that we grew up with it's like it's
weird because you feel like like [ __ ]
that was in the past you think that like
it's all gonna be forgotten about it
stuff no man that shit's all stole away
like I can look up I looked up like some
old shows like from [ __ ] PBS that I
watched I was a little kid and you can
see it you can see it again like
remember old games off the [ __ ] Apple
to computer like wizardry to it used to
scare me you know I call it man I felt
like I was in a dungeon somewhere Oh
like a dark dungeon and [ __ ] you look at
it now it's like [ __ ] like a cell phone
would blow that away
well yeah it was spooky back then you
know come on the Dungeons & Dragons game
but it's boring now
that's what's so funny about like I feel
like you know late and I'm not gonna
like [ __ ] on younger generously
that's [ __ ] sound like a little
person whatever but um you did kind of
have like the graphics back then were
notably shitty so you really did have to
use your imagination like onto [ __ ] like
you know you know and I said about the
et game which gets a lot of [ __ ] because
it was a terrible game but even the
games that sold well like the Italians
don't like Indiana Jones and stuff like
that those look pretty shitty too which
is very funny to me because the et game
did so poorly and it's very famously and
they buried them all in that big [ __ ]
landfill or whatever but it's like that
really didn't look any more shitty than
lots of other games that came out at the
time so it's just funny to look back on
and there was that much difference in
how people perceived it even though all
the games just looked like a bunch of
like squares
they're saying it's a car II I can't 8th
Rik yeah yeah that sounds about right
I have seen since I was a kid yeah I
don't even remember that and I remember
Rastan but I think there might have been
two Ikari warriors they might been like
a like a original and then if you can
run it apart - yeah cuz they came out
fast back then yeah because they were
easy cuz like it was just a bunch of
squares you so much like [ __ ] pixels
it's in really well Corey warriors was a
little more sophisticated than that that
was around the time that you had Space
Harrier was the one where you had word
you were in like a little vehicle and
you were like driving over them that was
like little bones moon Patrol Patrol
yeah oh I like that was pretty good I
don't know I don't know why Patrol is a
lot of older than like I said what I all
I remember i remember like really old
school ones that i played at the arcade
because like i said when i grew up right
next to my grandmother's house like
right behind her house was like a
7-eleven and he always had like two or
three like arcade games in there so and
he would switch him out like every now
and then so he had like BurgerTime be at
joust he had like [ __ ] gallagher or
whatever and like we'd go over there
like you know my grandma would give us
like handful quarters when we go over
there and play them and then we go over
and get [ __ ] you know who pies or
whatever and play them this so it's like
I remember those and then I remember
like the Nintendo and Sega games that
came
right around the time of like you know
the first castlevania the first Legend
of Zelda you know Tetris stuff like
that's why I remember that I remember
you know Sega's Sonic the Hedgehog I
remember the first Sonic the Hedgehog so
I remember those two gaming periods
anything in between that time or after
that time I don't really remember all
that well because I didn't really get
into it like I liked playing games at
those two times but I think like other
times it's just - another [ __ ] so a lot
of them I kind of remember cuz my
brothers played them but cuz I have two
brothers but um a lot of the other ones
I don't remember as well but you have a
lot of the ones on emulator right you
like I got I own all that old [ __ ] it's
not playable really today yeah you play
him for a little while and you're like
uh not as good as I remembered it well
because back then there wasn't like a
lot of options it's like now you can get
completely I mean [ __ ] you play fallout
and I'll just like sit there watch you
play fallout and be like hey go over
there and like do this and that the
other thing because it's like a whole
world that you can explore which in a
way kind of like blows my mind that
there's like so much [ __ ] thought that
goes into a like way more than a movie
well it's like a novel really because
you have to go so much into like all the
[ __ ] side quests you have to do and I
came and keep track of all that [ __ ]
they're talking about n64 n64 was an
awesome system and gold and I was one of
the best games of all times when gold
and I came out that was the one of the
first really immersive first-person
shooters and it's still good today I
wanted the reboot of it but you can't
buy it on xbox one the closest you can
get on Xbox one is perfect dark which is
that same engine it's really really
similar but there just a certain charm
to [ __ ] Goldeneye Goldeneye was good
that was like a big a lot of people
liked that game yeah there's a they're
gonna have a rerelease of Goldeneye
evidently but they've been working on
because these were like Oliver Harper
was talking about that and I feel like
it's like I said there was you know even
back in the day like people talk about
now like product tie-ins and stuff but
even back in the day it was probably
more blatant than it is now honestly
like every single movie that came out
had to have a video game tie-in even if
even if it was like a shitty one but go
I feel like gold and I was one of the
more successful ones
the thing with Goldeneye is it was the
first person shooter that was 3d but
you're only you were only doing one
joystick on that on the n64 I can poke
on controller so it was tough and you
had an aim button which changed the
function of the [ __ ] joystick so you
had to get that [ __ ] down right it was
just weird you know in distance it also
self aimed sometimes - I just had to
face the guy and it would hit him but if
you wanted to actually aim you had to
press in a like a trigger type button
and it would crosshairs what appeared
what kind of zoom in depending on what
weapon your hand and then you use the
joystick to [ __ ] control the gun yeah
and then when you weren't aiming the
joystick control the motion of the man
and then you had other buttons when you
weren't aiming you could have strength
with it was [ __ ] weird the controls
were weird you know they weren't it
wasn't a modern controller yeah that was
the issue with it would have been a lot
easier to to play with a modern Xbox
controller with two joysticks I mean I
said I think the only first-person
shooter that I ever really got into is
doom liked the original doom I liked
that but in general I liked puzzle games
more ones that were more like expansive
you know like I said I was really into
Zelda because you know you could go it
was like a whole entire little thing and
you could go and find things and like
figure puzzles out and [ __ ] like that
got a thousand yen I think oh thank you
very much Digital spider music must be
jammie-jammie is a Frenchman if I'm
Crick into the spider music is this
jammy plant - I think it is it's the man
that built those figures right back
there for me gel Pro latisha
believe that that's Jambi is a Frenchman
who lives in Japan who has Japanese
family and he does all the little
figures from Japanese seventies anime
from yellow Bing yeah and he wanted to
talk about making a new getter robo
remember that I used to have remember I
made a CD of like all the Thea's him I
gotta get thank you very much yeah yeah
right
hey there yeah I used to I have made a
CD because when you were doing when you
were working for a comic book store like
down there yeah and they were just
starting out like their Japanese were
about section or whatever and I had made
a CD that they could play behind their
new display yeah there was all the theme
songs from like all the Japanese it's
like yeah yeah theme song grandma's my
favorite we all do yeah cuz it was the
theme songs were all done by really
well-known Japanese singers the guy with
the Cape from the still around yeah yeah
I know who they were
yeah I can't remember the guys name the
guy song yeah and he was like he's kind
of like a almost like an Elvis type of
dude and he like always more like capes
and [ __ ] like on stage he had a great
[ __ ] voice but he did a lot of the
same songs for the all the different
cartoon shows with the robots and stuff
get a robot still my favorite yeah I
don't know why that is I gotta find that
CD man now I'm gonna like it's a rhino
so again it's yeah Oliver Reed was drunk
elite-level he was yeah didn't he die
did he die of liver disease augury yeah
or did he die of something else oh wait
he was a very famous up like very
famously alcoholic yeah I liked her oh
really cool dude when I was a kid
Oliver would scare the [ __ ] out of me
because he always seemed like he was on
the verge of flipping your [ __ ] axe
he probably like a a mean moment he was
gonna [ __ ] explode it was the alcohol
I guess that probably
that's another thing it just reminded me
it's like I know it says yes so we
watched last night like on to be they
have I don't know how old it is it's
probably like several years old but they
have like a documentary it's about two
and a half hours long called 50
I think it's called 50 best horror
movies you've never seen even though I
have to say that I've seen probably
about 95% of them but one of the ones
that they had on there was burnt
offerings and I was very happy that that
was on there very good I feel yeah we
reviewed it a while back and it was like
I always recommend it like if you love
some 70s haunted house because although
Reid is in it that's why I thought of it
but um that's one of the ones if you're
really into seventies haunted house
movies like I am and if you haven't seen
it also read the novel by robert moresco
because the novel is really good and I
also love that I love like the downbeat
ending I feel like they were I feel like
there was a time period when they were
kind of afraid they always had to make
like happy endings I feel like 80s 90s
everything had to like work out in the
end but in the 70s they were just like
no everyone dies just deal with it and I
feel like that was like better that's
scarier you know so they did that in the
movie and I really like that movie also
what was the [ __ ] movie where Oliver
Reed was like naked wrestling with it
that was [ __ ] goddamn it now Cameron
what's that is ex going on and he's also
saying we have officially been offered
we have three hours six minutes and 40
seconds I can see it right there there's
something I can't that's unbelievable I
can't believe we've been going on that
long
The Devil's oh man that's not actually
on my list to review we really had to
review that at some point have you ever
have you ever seen The Devil's no Ken
Russell same guy that did altered states
I'm seeing Oh altered states was a good
one though yeah we still kind of holds
up I have a lot of Ken Russell movies on
my [ __ ] like The Devil's I've lair the
white worm which I know is them balanced
kind of like one that people in either
kind of love it or hate it I really
liked it it's based on our Bram Stoker
story actually yeah it's super weird I
mean I love Kenny but
I still want to do it he did gothic too
didn't he which is about haunted summer
about Percy Shelley Mary Shelley Lord
Byron how are we doing on David Pike
that's oh I did want to mention 2008
yeah he ran for election to Parliament
okay it's an independent you know how
many votes he got guess how many guess
how many millions probably oh yeah I
feel like the crazy crazy you are
yeah pretty bad I don't know what it is
about the u.s. man the United States
likes extremity crazy people yeah its
extremity it has to be one thing or one
thing or the other
okay we don't like anything that's like
nothing ambiguous you know you have to
know exactly what it is and what your
gay fears terrible you have to lean into
the terrorists and then like a lot of
people would be a lot of foreigners get
very confused about it they don't really
understand American culture not been all
over the world and jennasmith [ __ ]
lived in Europe there's a big difference
between the American mentality and the
mentality other than other countries
the closest the closest thing to America
I would say in Prague in Brazil
Australia is kind of yeah I'll true but
I think I don't think I don't think
Australia is as wild as the United
States oh I don't know about that yeah I
really I living in Brazil I see a lot in
common between Brazil in the United
States when it comes to when it comes to
this Americans are used to being lied to
that's one of the things they don't like
any [ __ ] ambiguity to anything and I
heard a British guy [ __ ] described at
one time what was going on in and he
nailed it Americans do not like
intellectuals they don't like they don't
like
people that you use flowery language and
it's because Americans think that very
intelligent people will hurt you because
they can so they actually kind of like
plain-spoken people that are not they
don't like anybody that represents a
lawyer that's a good way I think they
don't like legalese you don't like
political speak they like somebody who's
just trying to be they like somebody who
just seems to be average even if they're
not even if they're not ending they have
to appear to be average they don't like
Indian now what is the average in
America the average in America is pretty
[ __ ] wild I think so
it might look extreme too in other
countries I would think well I don't
know it's that's the thing it's like I'm
an American to you but it's like I don't
I don't know if you can generalize
particularly because it's kind of like
not all Americans are like that because
I'm not like that I mean honestly when I
was in the UK I kind of felt like I
related more to the Brits in a lot of
ways that I did to Americans in some
ways just because the the outside
perception of Americans that's only a
particular segment of Americans that's
not everybody and that's not even the
majority really because I've found most
people are like I mean people are like
all over the [ __ ] map
you know what I mean so I don't know if
there's any way that you can generalize
to like Americans in general because
they're really even ones that I know
ones are born here it doesn't have
anything to do with like where they came
from ready but they're all very very
just got a look at who Americans would
say vote for president that that's a
dead giveaway
who could be president today aside from
say Donald Trump you who I think would
become a president would be the rock
I think Dwayne Johnson could could
successfully win a presidency now it
weighs nothing crazy but he could do it
it's crazy but in some ways
people would say that [ __ ] Donald
Trump that he he could never win
you don't know America yeah he could win
but sucking so could [ __ ] rock I have
to think 2-1 it's like idiocracy over
here but but it's not as dumb as you
think it is well I don't know like a
certain segment are I got dumb people
but there's a certain amount of wisdom
to being dumb I don't know if I agree
with that saying so oh is it
well I'm coming at this from a different
perspective I was I was thinking about
this the other day because you know how
we always say it's like you know like
I'm the Spock and you're the Kirk yeah
okay well sometimes I feel like me
personally I feel like I'm mr. Spock in
a world of mirror universe Kirk's you
know what I'm saying so that's kind of
where I'm coming from so like I said I
can relate to when I was in the UK I can
relate to this to that culture better
because they're more in a way they're
more reserved they don't get all up in
your face they're not like super wet
like a lot of some of them are but it's
kind of like they're more kind of like
hey I don't want to like get in that
person's business so I'm just gonna
leave everyone else alone and I liked
that they were quieter they were more
reserved I was into that I don't really
like and not all Americans are like this
so and I know that a lot of people have
perceptions of Americans are they're
very loud they're very obnoxious and I
saw you know people ask me about that
when I was there too not everyone is
like that I'm not like that and I
release it that's why I related more to
like people in the UK particularly
because a lot of them are not like that
too so I was like hey I like this like
everyone leaves you alone and you know
it's just that's kind of like accepted
that you'll just like chill out and like
let everyone like mine they're in
business and not get up in people's
faces and be like overly friendly
because they don't like that about
Americans where they're always kinda
like one thing that British people said
they're me when I was over there oh
thank you very much Matt um is that they
don't like when they go to America they
go to American restaurants and they're
like the the servers will just like be
up in your face like all the time like
hey how is everything how is everything
leave me alone I'm just trying to like
[ __ ] eat and it's like I get that you
know what I mean because
like this like fake overly friendly
because that is something that Americans
and it's not so much the people that
work there it's like the corporation's
kind of operations make you do that
because I worked at a record store and
that was something that was very much
pushed it's like every time somebody
comes in you have to like breathe hey
how are you because they have to like
you have to like saying that oh they're
seen so they don't steal anything and
like so you're trying to like make you
know you're trying to like be overly
like fake friendly and like a lot of
Europeans don't like that and I don't
like that either so I can understand
where they're coming from but you have
to understand too that like America's a
[ __ ] massive country every state is
different every [ __ ] city is
different every county is different so
it's like you can't really generalize
it's just like everywhere else our state
to the size of European countries some
of them
yeah and Florida for particularly is
like it's very very large and we have
like a huge I mean there's there's a
whole portion okay so there is a whole
set like section of Orlando which is all
Vietnamese people you know I mean it's
like it's like five blocks six blocks
something like that and downtown early
and it's albeit in these people it's
like so you can't really like generalize
about Oh Orlando people do this really
it's just like anywhere else it's like
and in you know I'm from Mississippi in
the early ages and my dad's from there
and that's kind of the culture base then
I kind of come from which is extremely
southern you know Mississippi is the
Afghanistan of [ __ ] Lee it's like the
tribal regions of the United States and
then I moved to Brazil and I actually
grew up in my teenage years in Brazil
and while I was in Brazil some of my
friends were [ __ ] British because you
know you have people from all over the
world and an expat type weird yeah and
in a situation like that I was able to
kind of meter the different [ __ ]
cultures like you know Swedes didn't do
too well in Brazil
neither did British people they spent
all and the Japanese just fail there so
I went to school with them well I don't
Raziel is like just full of oh brazil
Colombians it's [ __ ] Colombia raising
yeah and
they spend all their times in compounds
secured compounds safely away from the
reality that is some Paul I was
knee-deep in it all my friends were
Brazilian I didn't really like American
kids when I was growing up there I
thought they were [ __ ] um so I was at
home and all that you know what's weird
is that I loved it you know um
Nick Cave yeah there he lived well he
lived in Sao Paulo for a very long time
he was married to a Brazilian woman
Viviane current car here or I think her
name was for a very long time he [ __ ]
loved it there you know because he's
Australian in case you know but um he
loved the chaos of it he thrived in the
chaos which some people do from an early
age I'm watching military police [ __ ]
gun down bank robbers [ __ ] just out
in public with submachine guns [ __ ]
all these weird-ass shooting videos you
see on YouTube for self-defense courses
guys that's all Brazil yeah and that's
what I grew up in so I you know I don't
so I guess I guess I guess I see reality
just from a different people well it
like I said it depends on where you grew
up and honestly like I have the
personality type where I'm very much I'm
kind of an introverted person and I
don't like fakeness so I don't like
having to I don't like this you know I
know there's a perception about
particularly the southern United States
where everyone it's like very overly
friendly or they're like they come
across as so friendly that all this
comes across as fake which it does a
little bit it is though it is fake and
honestly um in case you're not from here
and in case you didn't know it's a
Southern person says do you bless your
heart
that means [ __ ] you that's not a certain
amount of duplicity there is and I don't
like that I don't like like duplicity I
don't like fitness I don't like anything
like that so me growing up in the South
I felt like a little bit of an alien
because I didn't really have so when I
moved to the UK and everyone was very
reserved
like hey man keep to yourself and like
you know don't bother other people and
like every we're just gonna keep to
ourselves unless something really
terrible happens I was into that because
I was kind of like oh thank god like
some people that actually know to leave
each other alone instead of like getting
all up in other people's [ __ ] but I feel
like sometimes it's not as bad as it
used to be back in the old days but even
now I feel like nowadays like for
example you know I'm out on you know
walking on the path or whatever and it's
like I'm always like paranoid because I
feel like people are walking past like
on the other side of the path and
they'll be like smiling or waving or
whatever and I'm like do we really have
to do this like every time a person
walks past me it's this really tiresome
I'm really just trying to like walk I
don't know you I don't really want to
like you know what I mean but then I
feel like if I don't do it then everyone
think like I'm autistic or something and
it's like that or I'm being an [ __ ]
but really I'm just trying to like get
my [ __ ] done I don't want to waste a lot
of time like waving at people I don't
know or like pretending I'm happy about
seeing people I don't know so like I
said it's the duplicity I don't like I
don't like having to like pretend that
I'm like people's friends when I don't
know them you don't I'm saying Steve get
Steve's in there if I can see that I'm
glad I loved it when I got some
[ __ ] in the audience [ __ ]
talking about me drunk makes you rock up
I [ __ ] wanna just makes you wanna
[ __ ] look he's gonna be digesting our
children that was a weird thing to say
when you [ __ ] off when you sit off into
it goes that actually made me pause I'm
explaining
[Laughter]
remember that write that down that gave
me birds actually it's nice like you
know what you said before about like
you're digesting our children we're
gonna put them yeah you guys just I have
so many I had to come up with some
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] counters I had
maniacs
what in the [ __ ] is that when you bust
off in a [ __ ] ass it goes up
into the lower intestines he digests it
it ends up becoming part of his
metabolism and builds his cells it's
kind of like cross between cannibalism
and having children so it's kind of like
Tom's DNA is like infiltrated
infiltrates your [ __ ] booty booty
walls and ends up building this Ranger
community okay don't make me make this
[ __ ] well I thought you were already
doing that okay it's an art form it
takes up it's a special art form it is
yeah yeah this is what okay so if
anybody wanted to know what it was like
like when we go out to the club and get
really really drunk like around the end
of the night this is about what it's
like except there are a lot more people
there's a lot more people and they
ending on this I got guys that come up
to me and we'll do this [ __ ] for an hour
talk about getting each other pregnant
never will and Yale will do that [ __ ] in
front of his girlfriend and I'm tell not
anymore she's like yeah she's not a girl
but her name was Andy she was this
chicken
thank you Matt drink up tell Andy I was
like she's actually getting scared you
gonna pay child support and fine I'll
[ __ ] with her all night long and I'm
[ __ ] with him too
I don't give [ __ ] she's like now I'm not
gonna be able in I would you know what
that would be
I wish that men could get pregnant that
would be hilarious to me hilarious
what about the [ __ ] topic though
we're getting drunk what did I said late
from the [ __ ] top what did I say 20
minutes ago I totally lost my place in
the notes I don't even know our mat mean
this is what you people have done to her
we already talked about reptilians
that's all I learned attack to you is
over and we talked about yeah we talked
early Madonna [ __ ] man I had a show been
going on three hours of 22 23 minutes
you guys want us to end the stream I had
[ __ ] about freemasons but it's like
everybody liked it and we kind of talked
about them before anyway so get on I
mean I IDs this one how drunk is Tom
right now Tom's pretty [ __ ] up
okay look well your new drunker my drink
cheerio John doesn't earn one wait is
the third one oh yeah this is equivalent
of like about if you went to a club this
is my second it's just like the
equivalent of maybe like eight or nine
drinks so this is quite a bit
we're seasoned out this is Highsmith
we're not alcoholics well but we can
drink we are alcohol consoles I would
say this is maybe like one third of a
fifth 1/4 of a 5th primary well well how
much of the okay I'm 13
you bought a bottle of tequila today
yeah this afternoon but a big one I
bought a big bottle how much of that
have you tried actually actually fit
it's a lot with the bottle that I bought
was a lot bigger than fit so probably be
like after fifth no less than one third
I mean when we were younger we drink a
lot like a fifth and a whole night it's
not as you know it gets harder when you
get older it's like it and it doesn't
necessarily hit you until the next day
the the shitty thing about it is that
you can drink as much as you did when
you were young but it takes like way
longer to recover than it used to like
used to be back in the day
I can [ __ ] drink and drink a drink a
drink
and then like the next day I'd get up at
like 6:30 and go to work and like
nothing happened but now it's kind of
like now it takes like two days later
I'm still like some chick named Melissa
Singh that just got here there are
wasted be able to rewatch it though this
is kind of fun man it's like you know
what I mean it's just kind of like
people seeing us I mean we do get like I
said we did it on the show it's like
this well yeah the regular show like
that I cut very little out the only time
I cut [ __ ] out is if we have a technical
problem or if I lose my place in the
notes and I space that I have to like
stop and like look [ __ ] up
so mostly when you see the recorded show
you're mostly seeing a live thing
because I don't take that much out but
the fact that you're seeing this in real
time this must be like a really kind of
I don't know I'm kind of I didn't I
didn't know it would be this fun but
it's actually kind of fun it's actually
easier it is kind of easier because I
because I feel like hey now it's already
done and I don't have to like edit it
the next day because like I said I
sometimes I edit it and like put photos
in and [ __ ] like that it's like now I'm
just kind of like [ __ ] that I want to
remember it do you remember back in the
old days when we first started and we
didn't have a video component we just
did the audio show and then I had like
just string together like four thousand
a million there's a lot of work on it
yeah it took a and once we started doing
the videos I was kind of like goddamn
why don't we do this the whole time
because it's so much easier this was all
something we just did experimental even
had to work on it to see what it is that
the audience wanted what was best for us
and we had to understand and and nothing
in steps a couple years ago and YouTube
was changing them yeah
live streaming they had it but it wasn't
really a thing as much two years ago so
Zach says I'm 23 and I lot get hangovers
you a yeah you will we could get a
little bit older I mean I didn't when I
was 23 either when I was when I was in
the Army in my early 20s I could [ __ ]
drink an entire fifth and then go run
five miles anymore yeah I used to go out
we all did it I used to go out almost
every night and dance and get [ __ ] up
and then I would just get and I'd go to
work the next morning
yeah like I would go out like pretty
much every night of the week and this
was like into my 30s and then suddenly I
couldn't really do that anymore like I
did still go out and get [ __ ] up but
then the next day I when I was in my 20s
I could jump on my [ __ ] old 16 engine
go ride [ __ ] eight hours listen some
chick knock it down for a couple of
hours then write eight hours back to the
[ __ ] fourth that's
what it's like to be young but when you
get older your priorities change your
hormonal profile changes it's just not
saying okay you don't like that ribbon
like I still love to drink I'm you know
not saying that I'm gonna you know and
if people don't want to drink I'm not
gonna like [ __ ] on you or anything like
that I like to drink I enjoy drinking
but as you get older you do kind of
start to question it's like you know do
I really want to drink this much and
then tomorrow I have to do this that the
other and I'm gonna feel like complete
crap so you do kind of have to like way
out cuz [ __ ] [ __ ] man I'm always so
you're already 50 I'm yeah I'm getting
there yeah I'll be 48 this September the
hard Jaguars back in the house with the
Mexican spirit he's just come back from
the top of the [ __ ] Aztec pyramids
cutting hearts out of [ __ ] sacrifice
Misenum to ship buh buh buh buh baby
some of the [ __ ] recipes that will be
in in some of the Mexican recipes that
will be in the cookbook are coming from
cop-con of Ocelot
they are vetted by an authentic Mexican
warlord we're gonna put down the
introduction to the second section in
that right picture when I hit your arm
you're gonna see ya somebody's Steve
McGarrett he says my hangovers are
catastrophic
I've been there um the best thing to do
but okay the shitty thing about this is
that I don't always remember to do it
like if I come home like because
sometimes the drunkest I get usually I
get drunk at home sometimes but usually
I just have to and then I fall asleep so
don't get any drunker but if I'm out
like and I get super [ __ ] up like I'm
like I'm just gonna go straight bread
debts tonight it took like five of those
and then like I don't remember anything
um what you need to do is the second you
get home drink a whole entire bottle of
water make two is better and take like
three or four aspirin before you go to
sleep you can't wait until after you get
up because then it's too late
um
if you take like a whole bunch of
aspirin and like two or three bottles of
water before you go to sleep it
mitigates it somewhat when you're old I
don't know about this was a secret that
I learned from a younger person who is
also a drug addict I was hidden [ __ ]
man-ray
big goth club down Massachusetts I was
working at the salesman up at Wellesley
Massachusetts was [ __ ] filthy rich
area I get drunk as [ __ ] [ __ ] the day
before it's been like [ __ ] 150 200
bucks at night in the clothes and lot of
Wednesday and that's gonna [ __ ] work
the next day and I'm [ __ ] here yeah I
just I can hit like four or five of
those lemon-flavored [ __ ] them for
lemon-flavored alka-seltzers yeah the
[ __ ] lock it down there that still
sell machines I was back and I [ __ ]
make like three to six hundred dollars a
day and that wasn't [ __ ] because my
[ __ ] apartment was like [ __ ] the
eighteen hundred dollars a month
yikes that's more than our rent now yeah
yes I get for a little bit a [ __ ]
apart and we have like a big
four-bedroom house yeah yeah eighteen
hundred bucks a month and then my name I
couldn't in my car [ __ ] payment and
then everything else and then all these
parasitic women than [ __ ] wat where
the word is well they want their [ __ ]
they want you to take them everywhere
you know it's just the way that scene
was back then we do like to be taken
the thing is is that they were good they
were like strippers and [ __ ] get on a
man [ __ ] well that's on you strippers
you they're just like hey buy me some
[ __ ] yeah well no they want [ __ ]
booze well that's a I don't turn down
free booze yeah I won't turn down free
to hell free anything well I don't want
to say free anything because it's like
then people say like hey yeah I know
what you mean but this it's like the
older you get like I said I still like
to drink
still drink at home because you know we
have been out a long time but um I feel
like the older I get you'd really do
have to like get ahead of the [ __ ] you
have to take the ass for a nifty trick
to water before you go to sleep because
if you wait until you go to sleep and
then you wake up then if you take
aspirin it'll work but not you'll still
feel like crap for like two or three
hours after you get up I found I say
it's about time to end the stream them
you think I think so we've been on for a
long time three and a half hours and
we're done we're done with the situation
with the subject um but it was great
seeing you guys and we'll be back for a
live stream next week did you guys enjoy
the live stream should we should we keep
doing it maybe we should like it then
maybe we should do these every week I
mean oh don't do it I thought it'll be
like coppercab you guys new copper yeah
they'll be like coppercab where I
[ __ ] let the string go for like five
hours and him [ __ ] yelling and
teaching you about [ __ ] intersexual
intersectional [ __ ] politics of [ __ ]
we're not going to do that okay you know
I'm talking about deal
I need opera cabbage well yeah I'd be
like coppercab I was like what we should
just leave the [ __ ] run in like all the
time but people would mostly be just
like looking at me like working on the
other computer yeah they're seeing more
live streams they love it
Khan is gonna go sacrifice a goat okay
throw that [ __ ] down in the cenote eat
it afterward they're delicious make a
curry out of it even though goats are
adorable and axes it's awesome we love
you too Zac whoa you guys I can't look
like all these people turn on facilities
exact I know you've got a gay Jewish
boyfriend but went once once once he's
done with you you come at you go ahead
and [ __ ] contact me and I'm hooking
up with a book of finest leather daddy
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] Florida can
offer you alright just make sure that
you've got some [ __ ] chaps on because
she's gonna work that [ __ ] raw when she
was his hands on you that [ __ ] [ __ ]
wraps around Toby would [ __ ] love you
Zack oh my goodness - Pookie what's up
hook's oh my goodness she's going
first appearance she has to be on the
show on the live stream is hey she's
been on the poor what's up folks and you
just now came in here yes sweetie
yay ah what's up little Pookie she's
like I'm gonna eat your microphone yeah
she's kind of confused about what's one
actually it's a little late that this
isn't it yeah she's like shouldn't you
guys he's in like leather daddies yeah
some [ __ ] Oh [ __ ] testosterone level
[Laughter]
no seriously don't stretch out for that
oh [ __ ] well he doesn't stretch out for
that I had your sack I had you pegged
for a size Queen yeah well you do have
to kind of I mean you do have to kind of
look at me I get stuff I had I mean I'm
glad cookie finally just came in for an
appearance I don't know what she's just
about every five on but we need to shut
this down it's getting like getting late
and the show's over we're so drunk
yeah we're drunk we gotta [ __ ] you're
probably drunken to me yeah but we've
had three almost three hours three hours
of 35 we'll be back soon we'll be back
next week glad she finally came in here
and she's lying down she was bright
under the porch she's waving in the
light of the are jeebies she likes these
lights yes she comes in and she like
sits in front of them in like six her
face approaches yeah she thinks it's
like a she's in weird like it's a heater
or something they don't put out anything
I wonder what they look like Derek
because don't they I mean can't see [ __ ]
you said booty walls booty wall what you
said that
I [ __ ] pulled this out of my ass you
guys [ __ ] 4d remember that song it
was by our sugar walls prince wrote it
yeah who did that I don't I say it he
made some [ __ ] that was kind of like
that so you know this is this was way
before that she lead no not really it
was on [ __ ] [ __ ] Sheena Easton Sheena
Easton that's ironic
Sheena Easton she talked about sugar
walls that was I mean obviously vagina
um and that was a prince wrote it right
yeah yeah well she is that her butter
kit in the camera at least I don't think
but yeah at least she came in for a
second so anyway oh yeah I've got a call
tonight people hopefully you guys
enjoyed the show we kind of talked about
at least we've got two Illuminati we got
your reptilians yeah I mean I kind of
knew this was gonna go off the rails
we'll do more live streams that will
project it yeah I like this I like this
format yeah we'll do it next week I
think you didn't I mean like I said I do
like the option of being able to edit
out when I like spaced out and like
forget [ __ ] because I'd like have we can
actually kind of play that we can
[ __ ] play that as part of the show
yeah because I'll make you space it out
look at her Rain Man ass or should I
forget where she was in her notes but
yes so I like I had a lot of notes oh
thank you so much whoa this gave us like
a huge that was read that's a big money
[Music]
we really should start doing this more I
know I didn't enjoy I was like like I
said I'm like I was paranoid about doing
this because I was stressed at I'm sure
I said about doing the Regular Show when
I could edit [ __ ] out when I can't in
[ __ ] out it's really you like it because
she used to like yeah I like it I like
live stuff and I like sponson aid yeah
and
I like reality type into entertainment
and interactive stuff so I actually
think it's a better idea to students but
shows live yeah yeah I mean we can't
always do them a Saturday night it's
done because sometimes I want to go out
Saturday it's been a very lucrative
night I think we've made at least 200 so
why not like I said that's not my
contributing what yeah and like I said
I'm really touched because I didn't I I
just did it because I thought it would
be a neat thing and that we haven't
really done it and I did and I did take
my shirt off for $10 real they made fun
of me [ __ ] $10 it man you're a cheap
date for the [ __ ] [ __ ] taking your
shirt off others I would need a lot more
than we didn't ever get that they seem
to enjoy alright so we're gonna wrap
this up we're gonna see you guys next
week
thank you everybody that dropped by
thank you everybody that contributed I
really really touched
thank you everybody that's like been
supported us for last book in 200
episodes I can't believe it even though
200 episodes [ __ ] we've done like more
than that cuz you didn't like look your
reviews and stuff but this has been like
an amazing journey and hopefully will
keep on going for years and years to
count on I don't have any plans to stop
because like I said I have [ __ ] two
years with topics and movies that start
to get around too so we'll be around for
a while for sure but thank you everybody
that came out have a good rest of your
weekend
you see next time thanks man thanks man
thank you very much thank you everybody
bye Batson he says flex Thanks do it
come on come on just right before we end
up there you go come on do it do it yes
Thank You Melissa
thank you oh thank you so much you guys
you guys are awesome all right we'll see
you next time